you could have driven a mini cooper with
the doors open
out of my penis and i wouldn't have
thought
i was supposed to go to work that week i
was out for [ __ ] [ __ ] drunk high
for two weeks
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god
hola with me george lopez
let's do the show
i'm gonna go to that directly right here
my kev phelps
neo sport sporting paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg
so they put it in there and how far do
they put it in there well just like a
lemon you know it's just an enema the
hose goes up there about this far
no
they just squirt you and then you let
your body rest yeah right they just then
you poop it out yeah and then you know
fluid goes in there
and then you you've got a few seconds
and you said you would you like us yeah
that would be good to use a mic
color it doesn't hurt your experience
i'm telling you
would you like us to uh
bring the we'd like us to find any
halloween candy
from a bedside toilet
and right across from the bed is the
regular toilet
and i said no no no no let's let's try
it you know i just make it if i don't
make it i [ __ ] on the floor you don't
have to clean it up they'll send
somebody else clean it up i say we go
for it how far is it
it's closer than from here to the wall
oh yeah it's like right from right here
to this one right so
i go in her and all of a sudden i i
guess i kick a little bit he says
in my ear i said no no that's why you
twitch i said well i was laughing
i said i was laughing because i could
just picture you after this first one
you're gonna be standing over there in
the corner smoking a cigarette
[Laughter]
so we got it out bam
it was good so
yeah you gotta do prep for that don't
you like normally i i had a colonoscopy
and i remember you're too young to have
a question but i had like some issues
and they were like so a lot of young
people now it's like colon cancers like
rising young people so they were they
were telling me why is that because you
guys are all stressed out no we're
eating like [ __ ] we eat like
yeah and so they told me they say you
need to get you need to get a
colonoscopy 10 years ago i wouldn't have
said anything because i had like just i
was bloated
and i'm kind of a hypochondriac anyway
uh and so they had me in but i had to do
the prep which was like you have to
drink this stuff drink the stuff
normally did you did you have you got
yeah you know how it is you came to a
toilet for several hours i wasn't clean
enough yet they wanted to stick it up
there oh so you did the prep and you
weren't clean enough yet yeah oh man
gosh damn there's a lot of intestine
inside this tabernacle
i'm sure that there is
and a lot of the pews are puked
like
the original the original the original
i don't know what they call that drink
you used to drink a hell of a lot more
than you drink now oh yeah i was in
cedars
and they gave me like liters six liters
and they're putting it on the on the
where they put your lunch in the bed and
they go hey man there's no hurry it's
three i'll come back at midnight you'll
be done with these things
a [ __ ] midnight i drank a liter and a
half
imagine going to the to santa monica and
standing in the water and drinking six
liters of that water it was
it was the
it was the worst thing you could ever
drink and i had i was drinking it until
like five in the morning man no i
couldn't the guy that was standing there
i said hey i can only do what i can do
like it just every time you took a
swallow you it was just torture man the
previous time
that i was in there because i was in
there three times last year you know
they said we need to give you uh we're
gonna have to give you an enema we're
gonna
before the enema they said we never give
you this medicine i said all right
because i was used to drinking well they
gave me some stuff that tasted gross it
was making me gag
but i finished it
that's what they don't do
so they came in
and they checked me out and they said
hey
uh
doctor says you're not clean enough yet
you know we're gonna have to do it again
damn
it's not coming you know what
you should have been embarrassed
what are you eating during your breath
hey you know what you know how you know
what that is that's like showing up to
like a formal and you're wearing like
shorts and a t-shirt like
don't come over to this place over here
and you still got choro and your sugar
walls in there
that's what they were saying you still
ha the doctor comes in here like listen
man you can't get like the little velvet
rope sorry man
they complimented me if you look at his
yeah and mine they show you they show
you pictures yeah it looks like
mcdonald's playland with no kids in
those troops
seriously
when you're clean yeah you could be like
i can see my [ __ ] tongue all the way
in there like
it it gets it's crystal clear you can't
i've seen it once by the time they went
in they show you that
i saw it going in i watched it
i you know they said we're going to
knock you out all right i'd like to
watch it i said no no it'll be too
painful discomforting you said you'd
like to watch it i said yeah
are you sure let me ask you something if
you were a sheriff right now would you
[ __ ] turn yourself in for being a
deviant
would you like to watch you like to
watch people take things in their oils
no no i want to see the inside not the
oil
you don't see it i want to see the
intestine i took seven years of spam
[Laughter]
i'm into that stuff you know because
i've been to as many autopsies i've been
to right i knew what the what it was oh
man i'd be able to spot something myself
you know if i saw something a pallop a
reddening uh someplace it was bleeding
i had a polyp you did pre-cancer so you
are you watching it on a screen like on
a screen yeah you see yourself but it
wasn't in color tv and i asked to be
awake too but they're like you don't
want to be awake you don't want to be
awake for this and so i i look you you
get in the room and they turn you on the
side and you see the tv but then you go
to sleep so you don't see the process
the anesthesiologist was an asian doctor
and she comes in she goes oh you big
and i said yeah obvious a lot of
medicine give me the good stuff you know
and i i had already asked if i could be
awake and the doctor said no so this one
said i said so they want me to be asleep
so i'm being give me a lot of medicine
so
she sticks it in there a little while
later
i hear the doctor saying well yeah bring
that right leg and put it over his left
leg oh god damn and i'm awake and i sit
there and i look at the dog i said hey
doc you want me to help you i can do my
own leg he says oh yeah go ahead it's
all right
so he did
this how are you how are you feeling now
i said well i feel like gumby but i'm
not in pain you know you're bending me
all the way i can do this
we finished i asked the nurse when we
were done i said
how much how long was i out you know
because
i was helping out she says you shocked
everybody she says you were awake for
most of it wow she said most people
would have been screaming and painting
nobody wanted to see a lot of people
they respond to like people but then
they don't remember like i just woke up
i didn't remember anything do you
remember anything
i'm always asking i i just remember how
the looby [ __ ] when i had yeah when
they gave me that uh
what's this that wasn't a cold offspring
yeah
i walked in there
michael jackson what what was the profit
profile
you don't remember [ __ ] when you wake up
that's one that you're out you wake up
it's like giving you a roofie i guess
yeah you don't remember anything
did you feel young
no i didn't feel young i just like a
young girl they told me they were going
to give me i feel no i felt the same age
i had one i had it one time and i felt
like i was 14 years old when i left i
felt so rested oh really but you're not
supposed to use that at home like i did
i did optometry at my house yeah but you
can't do anesthesiology at the house
they told me they were here that's what
michael jackson did and i just said
that's what i do i just asked him hey
i'm not gonna be able to dance when i
wake up you know there's stuff they gave
to michael jackson yeah but it was easy
[Laughter]
it was easy
do
how is it possible that somebody who
let's say weighed i don't know i'll be
kind
150 pounds i think it was less my weight
less than that how can somebody that
is that slight
take that much propofol because purple
fall
um
[Music]
incredibly powerful and you need like a
hundred percent anesthesiologist next to
you because they they hook you up to
respiratory or heart they're like
monitoring you the whole time yeah
how does somebody like that
can't get enough of that stuff yeah or
can't go to sleep if it's an opioid
right like you can build up a pretty
unlimited kind of tolerance for it like
people can do insane amounts of like oxy
or something if they've been on it for a
while it also uh it metabolizes super
fast so when you wake up
when you when they stop dripping it you
wake up ah it's really quick so you need
you need like a steady stream of it or
or else you'll wake up right my mom
worked in surgery she was
it was like a game they tell me because
i've had it
probably i've had that stuff at least
four or five times with all the
[ __ ] that i've done in the hospital and
and it's like a game they said okay
we're gonna get ready and i just how
high can i count before i'm out what do
you get to i've never gotten past three
yeah yeah they go for 100 and go back
down i got to
98.
i never got backwards from modern night
yeah
i was so i was so scared i don't like
being put to sleep i was so it was like
a controlled thing i was terrified and
they didn't really they were like
because i was super anxious i was like
doc are people normally this anxious
he's like yeah you just asked me that
two minutes ago no
was your first time going under yeah uh
no second time but i had my wisdom teeth
out and they gave me
but i was i was that's nightmare yeah no
because they mix it with uh prophethall
and they put versed there's like a
multiple like they give you a cocktail
yeah i woke up i called my mom a [ __ ] i
was like i was belligerent i was hitting
on the nurses oh yeah i was really a
mess i was i was a mess i was you
remember doing any of that no i don't
remember i i kind of i tell my mom i
don't remember doing it that's what i
tell my mom i said i don't remember mom
i promise i don't remember yeah because
you're supposed to stay in there until
you're not a threat to uh i've never
been a friend of that society
so you're good enough to drive a [ __ ]
latino player yeah here's your car keys
man
you can't find out which car is my
[ __ ] you're firing me or you're where
else what you're looking for
so
you got a clean bill of health clean
bill hell today was easy though they
were checking for prostate stuff i'm
cleaning the safeway chicken
tomorrow i go for uh
cardiologists
check out the i these guys
they want to do that procedure yeah
that's just what this is
this is the guy
i got a second opinion this was a guy
that was telling me what to do and i
asked for a second opinion so i went to
the
meadow meadow
and which is very rare because latinos
normally don't want even a first opinion
yeah we would rather not know
oh no
so i wanted to do it and i just
you know
because my primary care was saying i
don't know why he won't go in and fix it
yeah and he's trying to do with medicine
he says it's hard to do with medicine
and i finally just said you know what
maybe it's time we ask for a second
opinion so he said all right so i gave
him this doctor's name that i want to go
to and he said that's the best guide
cedars there is
and he's supposed to be world renowned
and people come from all around the
world you see him he's a valve
specialist in
cardiac business so
i went
and the first thing he said is he told
the physician assistant get in touch
with gil's
the other cardiologist
get in touch with him asking if he wants
to do the angiogram or if he wants us to
do the whole thing
and so he now knows and they got all my
records from him so he knows
that i'm doing this wow
and that's the one i got to go see
tomorrow
you guys are going to have it out well i
don't think so you're very similar be
offended though no well he may be
offended and i understand but when he
understands why i did it
and if he doesn't uh
doesn't accept it well it's too bad he's
not more than another human
but i won't let them work on me usually
they don't usually sometimes i think
doctors even though they'll say you know
ask for a second opinion yeah i don't
think they're happy if somebody no no i
i wouldn't be either in his shoes i
wouldn't be right but it's not
my and i'll explain to him my primary
care says he's concerned
over the amount of lasiks that they're
giving me because i only have one kidney
right
and over a long period of time he says
it's going to affect that kidney
and
we can't have that
you say you're not going to allow that
to happen you won't let it affect my
kidney but my kidney's only working at
50 right now so damn i said i'm in the
middle i'm not a doctor and that's what
i'll explain to i'm not a doctor i got
one doctor saying yes one doctor said i
don't like that medicine so maybe it's
time to get a sec let's get another
opinion if
the other cardiologist says he's doing
the right thing okay well then we'll
continue
but this guy right now at least he's
indicating
no he wants to do something okay i've
never said this before but if you need
another kidney i can ask my ass ex-wife
i'll give you mine she still has one leg
[Music]
i went in for my first kidney operating
when they were going to take it out
and it was my right kidney i'm going to
the hospital and my family's right there
my sisters my wife my kids and theirs
comes at mr creole and i'm all like a
tamale i'm already wrapped up in
everything they said okay mr grill
uh
which one would you be beef or pork
pork
she says
doctor would like you to sign have this
paper she wants you to sign him he says
it's your left kidney not your right and
i said no
it's my right kidney not my luck
she said well no you don't understand i
just got to phone the doctor i said you
don't understand
you go tell the doctor i'm not signing
the paper it's my right kidney not my
luck
and
so she went back she called it called
the doctor up
my wife is ready to cry she says don't
let them take you don't let them take
you what if they take out the wrong one
i said hey
you know that's happened everybody just
take a big chill pill i think it
happened to dana carvey i think yeah if
they take out the wrong one
we hit the lotto and they'll have to
find me a good one to replace it yeah
and you get money from it yeah so yeah
that's it the lotto the lotto's in
she comes back says okay doctor said
we're gonna take you down the operating
room we'll straighten it out down there
let's take it out down there
so we go down to the operating room
when
we took them both out the
anesthesiologist down there says good
morning mr crew he says i'll be your
anesthesiologist i want to know uh do
you know what you're in for today you
know what day it is i said yes again
today and i'm here for a nephrectomy
right kidney he says well close but
according to paperwork your left kidney
oh my god i said no it's my right kidney
i said doc i trust me
here's what happened here's the sequence
i've seen it i've talked
talked to the doctor talked to the
people that did the scan every it's my
right kidney i said i've seen it
and he says you know what he says i
believe you
he says if it were your
left kidney
we'd be putting it
in your right arm the ivs
because we need open on this side he
said but i believe you're right he says
so i'm going to start the iv on your
left side
meaning that now going on the right
kidney he said but i won't push any
drugs i'm just starting to port get it
open
when the doctor gets in here he'll be
able to uh clarify it the doc comes
walking in good doctor i like the guy he
comes in he's got his hands in the air
he's got a big smile he says okay you
win you win you're right
what i had was
i had sis the paperwork or screwed up
was the radiologist
oh my god
on the right side
mass on the left
but they didn't say
of the right kidney
also they said mass yes they just said
cis on the right side
mass on the left
side of the right kidney but they didn't
put on the right kidney
so he says i caught it when i came in
and realized this is not a problem
you're good thank you i'm not the right
one i don't think he would have caught
it
man i think it's about me
when i went back to see him after i got
out i said you know the other thing i
was worried about you came in there i
said you were wearing a ucla golf shirt
yeah and he's out he laughed he says
don't tell me sc fan i said big time fc
fan he's okay
he said i won i got the shirt at a golf
tournament he says actually i graduated
from notre dame that's all right that's
acceptable and he was good that's the
guy that i went to see today
yeah he's better right oh yeah he just
there's there's no problem is that the
one you were telling me about where
they're gonna go in up here
no that that's the
that's the
that's cedar sinai that's the
cardiologist
number two just gonna go in through here
uh to check my heart with the camera and
look at it
don't they going through the groin they
use they used to
use that was this one this one open your
ass
they're going through here now and for
an angiogram which they used to go
through your femoral artery
now they're telling no no we don't do
that anymore we go right through your
wrist
that's less invasive do that that's us
little cameras how do they do that
through a
[ __ ] vein
i don't know i dropped out of mexico
i don't know they use a gopro i think or
something a very tiny gopro camera
all right so you ready for wine
i'm ready when i had my kidney
transplant i was more concerned about
the catheter
than i was about the actual surgery and
one question i forgot to ask was does it
hurt like a [ __ ] i gotta buy a
truck
and then
the catheter's in
and uh you know you're in pain the guy
goes uh
we're gonna be taking that out tomorrow
that [ __ ] catheter was if you went
stood in the street and kept pulling
that catheter was about
15 feet long
so i go oh man there's blood on it's on
the ground like oh my god so then they
go i'd go to the doctor they had to take
one of the stents out
wasn't prepared guy comes in he's got a
thing with a long thing what's that oh
we're gonna uh take your stent out
and what you go like through here he
goes oh no through your penis
and
he just gave me like a local that little
numbing solution and i
i was oh my god i don't think i've ever
felt anything
more painful in my life so i still have
another stint in
because we'll take the other one out
next month well i mean it was awful man
oh dude and then the next time
5 30 of vicodin
6 30 half a vicodin
7 30 another half of a fight
i get over there they give me their
medicine so chicago dude i go hey man
give me another one oh doctor
all right so get back double dose checks
the hallway you could have driven a mini
cooper with the doors open
out of my penis and i wouldn't have
thought
i was supposed to go to work that week i
was out for [ __ ] [ __ ] drunk high
for two weeks
because that first one caught me off by
by surprise so much it was so painful
yeah that i said when the next one comes
out i'm not going to feel anything but i
i'm almost old deep
being surprised
at that never lie wrench
[Laughter]
man it's not i had any surgery
yeah teeth colonoscopy
that's it i had a with your colonoscopy
what did they tell you that was dye
related like you had a lot of so they
they
removed it they removed the
pre-cancerous polyp which evidently
could be cancer nine ten percent chance
it could be cancer so not even that's a
high chance tired yeah higher than
normal
so they said uh they said you just got
to change your diet and quit eating so
much steak
or something and we'll see you back in
seven years you still eat a lot of steak
no i eat chicken now all chicken chicken
and turkey i don't like turkey i just
like chicken i eat steak every once in a
while on occasion but i used to eat
chipotle every day
double steak bowls okay every day after
i worked out well i think that's that
probably that's probably what god could
be a correlation yeah so i used to i
used to every time i'd work out because
the steak at chipotle is leaner than the
chicken yeah yeah yeah which is less so
i was you know i was on my fitness grind
thing and you know do you know how the
digestive system works
not well
i'm on my fitness grind thing
how do you look good man you lost weight
how much weight have you lost 25 pounds
hey
keep going to get cold
it's time i got to plan my days because
right now i'm actually bloated are you
still going all the bubbles from the vfw
and yeah partying yeah i went there
as a matter of fact when i'm here
from here i'll go to the vfw he goes to
bmw with some old dudes there's more
hanging around tuesday nights so i'll go
from here
straight to vfw oh yeah
is that vietnam uh veterans foreign wars
i was in vietnam yeah
i'll go there
[Laughter]
oh you big come in oh yeah so i'll be
there for i'll i'll have a couple of
drinks then i'll go home
i respect the hell out of that i would
say this i don't care what age you
anyone is
if you have a pain or you have something
that happens you you got to get checked
there's a lot of people that listen to
podcasts and do stuff about health but
then there's a lot of list people that
listen to ours and wouldn't necessarily
seriously focus on their health because
our culture we don't really do that yeah
but don't think because you're young
that you couldn't get testicular cancer
or
liver cancer or you know uh esophageal
or whatever yeah
because because there's no
you know we just think we were growing
up if some like my grandmother's awesome
she'd see a little kid with glasses and
she'd go george
[ __ ] kid i said well he's wearing
glasses he's [ __ ] brand new well he
hadn't seen [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that was awesome i still remember his
safeway as a little kid with glasses of
my grandmother just shakes her i i guess
i'd do the same thing to mine but i
usually go like this i go what
i didn't see [ __ ] he has glasses on
that's a really [ __ ] great one
but you know everybody should especially
women if they're bleeding or
anything blood on your stool or anything
you know discharge outside this turn
like i'm a [ __ ] discharge
but yeah because a lot of our [ __ ] goes
overlooked and we could live longer
but we don't live long yeah that's what
we're gonna check we could be enjoying
the fruits of like look at guilt that
fitness will help so we have to look
forward
i had a bleeding ulcer
and there was blood in my stools
and so
my my bosom buddy my
this guy we work together east l.a lives
in havasu we get drunk together
and we drugs together matter of fact i
told the story about it last week that's
the guy where we were we thought we were
we've been drinking all day and we
thought she was making us food oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was awesome so i just talked to him
this morning and uh
we're talking so
i forgot what i was going to say about
ralph
there you go that was the first
time
i told him i was i was bleeding and he
said well how'd you how did you know he
says
well because i saw a bunch of blood
coming out of my stools
and he said what are you doing checking
your [ __ ] out for it just don't look see
you don't have to worry about it you
don't know what it is you don't feel is
that your first doctor or law suggests
your friend no that that's my friend
sounded like something your first doctor
would say no
don't look yeah and the first thing he
told me too hey if they tell you to stop
drinking [ __ ] it get a second opinion
there you go you don't need that doctor
but when somebody tells somebody like if
a doctor tells you to stop drinking like
you don't drink any heart stuff though
right
i used to drink a lot of hearts i'm not
anymore mostly wine mostly wine that's
all i drink now but is that in
do you think someone benefits from not
drinking entirely
oh i'm sure
i don't drink very often
i don't see much but you feel better you
work out hey i i see i i never got this
you know people say if you eat good you
feel better
i don't feel any different when you eat
like [ __ ] and i've eaten
i remember george burns when he was
doing his one-man show before he passed
away
one of the questions they asked him was
what does your doctor say
about you being 98 years old still
drinking scotch and smoking a cigar
he said which one most of my doctors
have died already
yeah it's true you don't know look at
keith richards or somebody like that
yeah look at jerry garcia
he's he like needs the drugs to function
yeah there you go you just i think it's
i think it's mostly genetic i think it's
when it's your time it's your time yeah
there's that but but would you live
would you be happy if they told you not
to drink any alcohol at all and told
perla to make sure that you don't drink
and tell your friends i would you're in
the presence of guilt don't let him
drink i would give up drinking in a
heartbeat so long as you don't tell
pearl first because then pearl's going
to be all over me
like a hug that's what i'm saying it
wouldn't
when they took out my kidney
first
post-surgery visit
i said when can i go back to work first
of all he says you're looking great
great color you sound good
look strong
i said okay
when can i go back to work
whenever you want
i said why can't i
when can i jump back he says whenever
you want
and i said
okay one last question what about
drinking now that i only have
do i have to stop drinking
totally prepared to accept no more
drinking all right
i said what about drinking
and he said wait a minute you're the cop
aren't you and i said yeah he says why
are cops supposed to drink
i said well they do he said well then
continue drinking
you're gonna have a normal life just go
on so he didn't stop me if at any time
anybody told me it was for medical
reasons or i was having a problem
at stopping a heartbeat okay so when you
guys were going to that bar
downtown some hideaway bar right in
chinatown
and you before and before you go home
you would go over there and have a drink
what are you guys
drinking for to relax to go over stuff
relax or is it just down take it take
everything off your mind you don't like
yeah it's just going there relax shoot
the [ __ ] you don't go in there off duty
yeah and and so and at that time uh at
that time i was drinking uh incredible
gold
and so you drink incredible gold if you
have one you may as well have a dozen of
them because it gives you breath of a
buffalo's ass and you know and i'd get
home and the wife would
you know you've been working yeah it's
like yeah just kind of
it smells like you've been drinking you
know so it was upsetting
i could tell you what what time my
career what i was drinking
but for years now all i do is drink wine
and
and that was it that's it
does it hurt a lot of guys that they
drink too much like those guys that are
like older detectives and
they've kind of seen everything well
some guys get become functional
alcoholics
you know they do their job some just go
too far some it eats them up they gotta
quit they gotta retire
medically it it tears them up and ages
them
and it does and for before i retired i
remember uh on my own i just quit
drinking bam went cold turkey
and was it tough
no no i just said that's it not gonna
drink
for a year i didn't drink i'd go out
with the guys have a glass of water and
have me a coke or something and i didn't
care i'd have just as much fun
with it without drinking but i was the
only guy that was drinking the dining by
retirement
we had about 450 people over steven
steakhouse and i had ordered shot
glasses
and it said uh cheers
you know gilchriot my working time
and uh on the other side i said my day
begins when yours ends
and did you make one just for you or for
everybody for everybody okay because
usually chicano just make one for
themselves no you better pass it around
so everybody can look at it as a matter
of fact i'm glad everybody didn't drink
because i only made like 300 of them
we didn't i didn't expect that many
people they were
putting people next door
and said hey go eat drink do anyone
after the ceremonies come on over
so i did this and then i said when i get
up to talk
have the staff
just start going around getting anybody
wants a shot at the gala just pass them
all out
and do you remember what you said yeah i
said there was a guy we had an
undersheriff by the name of larry wally
why did they cancel my talk show i'm so
good at it
there was a guy there was a guy named
boy and i'll never hear the end of this
one there was an undersheriff number two
command larry waldy
and at that time
if anybody got in trouble off duty due
to drinking
he'd put it on blast you know go out on
the
the inner department what would dudes do
like have a little domestic violence or
no driving drunk driving yeah you know
gets it well
so-and-so got stopped brought
embarrassment to the department again i
remind you don't drink it and so he'd
lay you out
and so
i didn't touch for a year the night of
my retirement i said okay
for those of you who don't know me that
well i'll just tell you right now i
haven't had a drink in over a year
and don't worry
i didn't have any problems didn't get in
trouble i just stopped
the truth being owned i didn't want to
give larry waldy a shot at catching me
dirty cheers to all oh that was nice all
right
so that was that was our chair
and
then i went back to drinking again and
then what was how about uh was it
difficult to be retired after because
you were such a job that is like a high
pressure thing very it was a very it was
very difficult yeah
depression
because you get up and usually used to
going for somewhere for a long time how
long were you in vietnam yeah 38 years i
gave the department i still wake up
early to this day oh yeah i'm i'm up
early every morning
and now just the only difference now i
just open up my ipad and start reading
all the stuff you have a scanner
uh no no no no and i saw the sheriff but
i think if you did have a scanner i
think you'd just put that
like a little bracelet with two slim
jibs under there
you're trapping your candy
no i i still love the department i love
love the way they do it
about six months after i was gone i ran
into the sheriff
uh one of my daughters was graduated
from misawa college
and uh
so i saw the sheriff who was there and i
was on crutches they just replaced one
of my knees
and he came hey well so what's going on
retiree and he was kind of jabbing me
because he didn't want me to retire when
i did
and i said nothing he says how are you
doing i said i'm a light i won't
[ __ ] you i said i miss it i miss the
call outs i miss working with the
professionals
i miss talking to young deputies giving
them a ray of hope
there's something left in this career
other than pushing around a radio car
and he says well he says
get well come on back and i said no
i left for the right reasons i was at
the top of my game i'm not bitter about
anything and it was time for me to go
i'm not a yes man
and i didn't agree with everything so
just time for me to step on down so when
you said i'm not a yes man was that a
little bit of a shot at that dude
it was
the way things were going it was the way
things were going you know at a time
where we had to
uh
you know the computers things are going
to change like that at someone at your
at your in your time of your life
i think
because if it's going to change to some
new thing cameras and computers and no
i'm not i'm not i i computers
i don't the cameras don't bother me they
they help us
i really believe they help us
uh clear up anybody who wants to make
allegations and if you're dirty it's
gonna hurt you right don't be dirty you
can't get hurt
but it wasn't a time where
you had to watch what you said on the
computer you know people send jokes they
do this
so there's a policy you can't do that
and they they just monitor your computer
as well they jump in there see what
you're up to
and
i'm was a team lieutenant i had 14
investigators working for me so i had to
tell them don't mess on the computer
don't send me all this garbage did you
guys do yeah i said i i'm telling you
right now i'm not going to rat you out
but if you send it to me then they check
on my computer i'm going to get in
trouble and i'm going to get spanked
harder than you guys because i'm the
lieutenant so don't do it i'm not a
prude if it's that good send it to my
house
you know and i'll look at it there and
enjoy it
and and i understand because that's
policy and i was willing to take the
punishment
for not acting on their policy
so but that's because you're from
another time yeah everyone else would
have rolled over on whoever sent that
yeah that that's policy i'll take my
lumps okay i did it wrong
but on the same
side
they were going through a budget crisis
and i was asked to come on up with an
idea
a plan where we could go out and work
murders without costing any overtime and
i told him i said you can't do it we're
not we don't schedule murders we're a
reactionary force yeah yeah
so
you can't
don't kill anybody
[Laughter]
eight hours at the end of the day i'm
going to tell you okay uh so your shift
was eight hours yeah we work a regular
eight hour day anything over eight hours
you get time and a half so
i put in a regular day
i work an eight to four job and then all
of a sudden they call me out at six six
in the evening to go to a murder
well
that's all time
and nobody complains
nobody complains about that that's the
nature of the job it's not a job it's a
lifestyle and you understand it if
you're going to be working murder if
you're working murders you can't check
out at 4 30 like hey man i gotta go man
yeah lopez uh i'll i'll talk to you
tomorrow i'm done with my eight hour day
today i'll talk to you tomorrow just
leave the body here yeah yeah
you can't do something they wanted us to
come up with a schedule i said
and i told them and i was the only
lieutenant there with our accountant but
it never worked for everybody you can't
do it it's impossible
and you got to find a way to a better
way to pay guys though because
that's like a drain on the it is on the
system it is working and
but you can't because that's federal law
federal standard labor day you know the
fsla
if you work over eight hours they've got
to compensate you financially
so
they weren't going to do it
i had reached i was coming up on 60
years of age i had 38 years already so
rather than bump heads because i was
told and if you can't come up with one
we will also transfer those of you who
can't go along with the program
so i said i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
bump heads with anybody if i don't need
it i'll leave
so i told them i said in a day where we
have to
worry about policing computers but yet
i'm supposed to turn my head when
somebody's violating federal law i said
it doesn't work like that i can't do it
and so therefore it was time for me to
retire and i did i'm not sorry i did you
didn't go forward to you in 38 38 yeah
and and i miss it today
i read about these things i still get
excited i still get pumped up
uh my wife we were at steven's
steakhouse not too long a few months ago
and
we're leaving and as we're leaving here
comes the helicopter and he's coming in
low so i saw [ __ ] something's going on
and i saw eunice going red lights on
siren northbound on atlantic
and your pulse just starting
normally i'd get on the freeway right
there i said yeah we're just going to go
this way so i went up went up and got to
goodrich and i could see the helicopter
orbiting now they're over here and i
could see units going on winter
boulevard now going eastbound
so i went right behind the big kmart
shopping center there because i can see
i said and there it is and so i go up to
all the cop cars are there and my heart
is racing this is police work this is
cool
and my wife said what are you doing
you're getting ready let's get out of
here
the other way some cop comes over and
he's flagging me down like hey ben can't
you see yeah yeah he's flagging me down
he says oh sir hey how you doing and
sorry sir i said no no i'll get out of
your way and hurt what's going on oh we
just had a little short pursuit three
armed robbery suspects we got two of
them one still in the area
and i said okay hey you guys be safe
yeah turn around
i want to have police ride along one
time
so yeah and that's
i mean we got i got i got kind of a i
live in a very nice area so there's
nothing going on
i don't know what [ __ ] area that is i
live in a nice area
i lay in la's that way though right i
don't know man
it's spotty right i don't care where
you're at it's a little more [ __ ] well
no but there's like nothing
well i don't know introduce our guests
because
uh so we have the man known as austin
show i don't know did you go by phone
yeah
and you can you can speak to this we're
in the middle of nowhere like sort of
kind of pioneered some programming on
twitch right yeah like lover host and
stuff like that was that you yeah so
that's me that's me i do uh reality tv
based content on twitch which used to be
twitch used to be a gaming website yeah
and then it became uh
more than gaming okay explain to guild
okay cause i got twitch when i and i did
a thing a golf thing over there on
wilshire that was on twitch and i know
how i know how powerful twitch is oh
yeah yeah so explain to because we got
them into what are you now in clubhouse
and instagram okay okay huh so now we're
going to get you on grinder grinder
[Laughter]
faster than grinder you get a blow job
faster than uber eats i'm telling you do
you know what grinder is
oh it's it's a gay hookup app and you
you you go you go what yeah
oh my god hi
yeah tell them so it's a gay hookup app
you you you you download are we talking
about twitch or grinder no let's talk
about grinder
so you get grinder right it's a gay
hookup app you go in you put in your
profile picture and it
populates a bunch of guys all in your
area so if we're all on grindr like you
said two feet away
oh okay and then then you can send them
messages so you could get
a blow job quicker than ubereats and
unlike a tinder or something where it's
it's just showing up in a kind of random
order like it's greater sorts by like
how close they are just absolute
products if you're looking for a best
buy and then
it says bedtime near me near me yeah
it's
it's the near me yeah right it's yeah
it's right some some people be like oh
i'm in your hotel like right down down
you're you know it's serious man it's
that's it's serious but see and and also
in the gates i think it's dark though i
mean is it is it dark it gets a little
messy yeah i think it can be because you
know it's a little bit of like
you know some deviants you know i mean
you don't know man like everybody's a
little bit i don't know i don't know but
you're a officer like i think those
things
i don't know man like do they
when people
sometimes they don't mean well there's
some predators out there for sure i mean
that's a predator it would be if you're
a predator that's where they are hundred
percent like no barrier to entry even no
there's no barrier
i mean you just sometimes like the hello
on grinder is a dick pic
yeah just like that's the first thing
you see from somebody is their penis
that's serious so try it out tonight
we're gonna put in your phone go to the
vfw and if there's about the five feet
from you
that's willing to give you an opinion
back there you want a colonoscopy
you don't need insurance
my doctor might be on there
i just ordered all these shots my cooler
wasn't entirely clean
who's the guy that uh used to have the
show to catch predator yeah chris chris
hanson was a bigger criminal yeah
that got a bigger criminal than the
people he used to set up he was
streaming on twitch i think what did he
get for bad chicks yeah uh
taking money and besley
wow he was the man yeah he's jack you
don't see keith morrison going through
that [ __ ] i will still have heroes
[ __ ]
that's what i'd be you know you go on
this grinder
there's a there's one of those guys to
catch a predator right behind the others
okay so so when that when apps started
uh
what were the most popular ones at first
were they news apps were they i
i remember there being like novelty apps
were big at first where it was like
especially when iphone first came out
there was one that everyone i knew had
it was just called beer and it was like
it would load up a little like picture
of beer on the screen and you would tilt
it like you were drinking it and it
would like fake sort of for the lighter
or the candle or the zippo lighter right
where you could ultimately
do you remember that so you know what
they do now is in our day you could burn
down the la form but the the form in
england oh yeah with a real lighter and
now they get a a lighter app on your
phone or they just do the or they just
do the thing yeah yeah you know where
imagine that you're
you're in a
18 000 people
and everybody takes a lighter and
[ __ ] 17 000 people have a lighter on
yeah in in in indoors yeah and if [ __ ]
caught on fire
[ __ ] nobody'd be able to get out
everybody tramples everybody else 99 all
over again woodstock 1999 that thing
over there in jersey where that that
band great white use the pyrotechnics in
a place like this where there's like old
wood and this [ __ ] went up under man how
many 400 people died god damn they just
didn't think about it but you if you
how
i want to say unprotected we were but
you never heard of
an arena catching off in england you
know with all the stuff but not
not here those are dangerous [ __ ] man
like oh yeah
but then also as a society we weren't
lighting [ __ ] on fire like woodstock you
see what suck 99 i
it's pretty good you should see it i i'm
gonna go is it you saw it i haven't seen
you know it documentary it's only oh
it's a documentary right
hbo but it's about a time before yeah
before everything was documented and
before all of that so as those apps
start to go and then i think tinder and
then some of the bumble
tinder that's are you on tinder
i'm not i was
are you are you ryan man
i'm a brian man there we go i need to
get on that i hear my friend hassan he's
telling me you know what i'll pull some
vehicles on there yeah
but you know what it's almost like some
girls say why are you on there and i
said well you know
i said it's like fishing
but leaving you're walking away and
leaving your hook in the water that's a
good point it's serious it's good that's
a great analogy and so ryan gill is it's
like a sort of more elite kind of dating
app where they thought all right where
these other ones have you know
uh anyone can sort of sign up you just
verify with like a facebook yeah right
i've had girl influencers that i work
with and they're like
on the other side of the country and
they're like yeah i'm match with you i'm
like i you know what man it's a trip man
right because you know because you're
he's on the good side of it but
tinder there were tender killers
craigslist killers
craig i remember the guy there was a
doctor going to medical school on the
east coast where they caught him in a
hotel going to nice hotels he was
killing uh females
i mean how long craigslist
so there's two cycles out there right
now right yeah oh yeah i had somebody i
had somebody take my instagram copy it
everything on it and message girls and
he would call them and they people would
see come up on their instagram they
didn't have any privacy settings it
would say my name on the thing and
they'd answer it and be like hey and he
was just dick out
how easy is how easy was that oh super
easy easy and it took them like it took
them up just a few seconds to do it and
it took like 12
hours to get it then he'll just do it to
like until they catch them there's
there's people that send me things and
go hey man probably you too like they're
like hey this guy's pretending to be you
he's not you he's reaching out hey i
like to talk to all my fans well
if it's that they know it's not me
[Laughter]
if you're a fan or not tsa if i'm
engaging with which i think is the best
way everybody's looking to be like i'm
like i'm old
enough to take you know take a few
people not liking me
so then so then uh how did you start uh
how did you start doing what you did
what you do so i i i twitch is a gaming
platform originally so twitch started in
what
recently
2012 games yes mostly exclusively gaming
right and so that's how it started it
started as a gaming platform and nobody
really did anything but games in fact
you weren't even allowed on twitch to do
anything about game you had to do gaming
or else you got bad gaming like examples
like uh
legends league of legends uh world of
warcraft
runescape uh you know you'd have to play
these games any games you can play but
but those are the biggest popular league
of legends i was like do you know league
of legends
i did computer games you know games did
when you what was around when we were
kids like
pong and all that stuff
listen man my dad got pong he was
telling me to think it all started with
pong
where you'd hit this [ __ ]
loot it out
babe and then it'd [ __ ] take a half
hour to get over there
and then come back and then it would you
know did it speed up oh yeah it's better
okay
by the [ __ ] middle of october
but you know i'm an only child and i
never got into
like that stuff like uh game boys or or
even an atari or any other stuff like i
never i never got into it and some kids
i don't know if that
could be only children like i don't i
don't know what makes a kid uh do that
i'm not really into gaming myself so i
grew up with games right i played
flights this is yeah i just want to be a
pilot so i used to play flight simulator
which is like not what most kids like to
do right i play flight simulator i used
to play halo i used to play madden you
know all these games so i grew up in
like as like sort of like a gamer but
never serious so when i went on to
twitch i always love reality tv i always
like like these these shows i love
comedy i watch i watch i watch your
standup i love stand up i love that kind
of stuff i love reality i love real i
love you know i don't like the super uh
you know scripted stuff and i'm not
really into games so what i used to what
i did when i came on to twitch is i
started you know bringing people on and
bringing people together and and we
would just talk you know sorry so like
what i love to do is i'd like to bring
on the audience and so like i'd love to
involve the audience so the early
renditions of my shows were we bring
people in
uh and we'd have like a group of people
and we just bring people in on the audi
from the audience to chat with us uh and
could you see him or just hear him first
we just heard him and then we eventually
brought in their video and then that was
like a step right yeah
eventually we started building formats
around these like uh formats around
these these uh
these these ideas these occasions
and then it became i love no everybody
loves dating right everybody i mean
everybody has something in common with
dating or i mean not everybody loves
dating you shouldn't say that
but well
we've all suffered we all we all have
something to relate with it right so
what was the biggest okay go ahead
because dude that's a good question so
we have we have we all have something to
relate with danny so like this show came
about called lover host which is the one
that that he was mentioning it's
basically it's an elimination-based
dating show where we have one
big purse let's say you
uh on the show and then i then will cast
10 girls and then you'll eliminate one
every 20 minutes until you find the one
that like you're most interested in and
it'll be a series of questions to figure
out how you eliminate and but the catch
is is called lover host right on twitch
if you choose if all the girls before
the show they choose love or host love
meaning okay i'm interested i want to go
on a date with george right i want to
pursue something afterwards host is
this feature on twitch where if i host
another channel i give all the viewers
to that other channel so whoa all the
girl the girl if the girl at the end
chooses host then she gets all the
viewers from the channel
and the guy walks away empty-handed
so he's trying you're trying to make all
these decisions move through the show
make all these decisions whilst trying
to dodge
who is there for the wrong reasons and
then every at the end of every
elimination you reveal what that's
pretty good yeah so it's really
entertaining
like a cooler griffin
so that that right there
would that work on tv
so i i think it loses its char
the
maybe the
the fun of it i think tv to some degree
yeah i think you can do some things on
tv but when you go to traditional you
know you got traditional digital digital
is what i do
and like i think it's more fun it's more
it's highly engaged it's authentic it's
real it's not scripted you know i've
worked with a lot i've been you know
early on i've started to work with some
more traditional folks because the
twitch has like risen up and so now the
traditional part of the industry is like
starting to i've worked with some
traditional you know
from the traditional side
and it's like sometimes it's like
everybody wants to spend a ton of money
on production everybody wants to spend a
ton of money and it's like no i just
need a computer and like right and my
people on zoom and we can do this whole
thing and a bunch of people will watch
it um so it's just like more authentic
it's more you you know you know what
traditional like you you had a tv show
right there's a wall that between you
and the audience that's right twitch
it's like
it's broken down right like it
you know it it it it's not and a big
part of of twitch too is twitch chat
right so maybe if you want to explain a
little bit and i'm not super sure how
much you fully integrate that but in
general like part of the appeal of
twitch versus something like you know
just a show well while the show is on
though you're people are responding to
yes you got live jail time so if we if
we were live on twitch right now that
screen or one of the screens here would
have a chat and it would just be moving
and a bunch of people would be talking
and you'd just be sort of reading the
chat uh and you can't really read it if
you know if you have a lot of viewers
you can't really
yes that show that show would not
benefit or i would not be interested in
something like that because i married
right you know so that's abating
you wouldn't be interested in
participating but you'd be interested in
reading because even like that lady said
last week like am i a third night you
had a story on that tape with a lady
last week
yeah a gal came on who asked like every
once a year she's like i i love my
husband but about once a year i just
really want to cheat on him like yeah
yeah well is something wrong with me
okay tell me
okay i thought puta was [ __ ]
but no no cabron is like a [ __ ] yeah oh
okay cause i thought cause puto is like
is one of the best words in the world
okay so what what is puto and puto is
like an [ __ ] he's an
always call [ __ ] a
guys
they have a lot of they have a lot of
similar it's how it's it's how it's said
i thought it was i thought it was it
could you know what it's how it's how
it's said you say hey because the first
thing i learned in spanish you ready
to moderate
that was the first thing i learned in
spanish it was the first ever word
before i went to spanish class and you
know what in spanish class back when i
was in seventh grade they used to give
us all spanish names for some reason
yeah of course
you worked in a restaurant too my name
jorge oh yeah that was my name you and i
had the same name
give him your phone so you can get on on
twitch yeah i mean sir yeah yeah
so we entertain so so how did how did uh
how did that become monetized uh how do
things get monetized so i think you know
where audiences where audiences come
brands will follow right so uh i think
over time first initially it was uh
twitch started selling ad space
on on the website like the company did
and then we get a cut of it and then
eventually brands came in
and then brands started paying the
influencers
independent from the website
so it just happened with time as it got
more popular brands were like what's
this let's get involved in this
and uh uh i'll go to your app store
i'll put it on here
um it's a big thing girl even even you
know how you're talking about like uh
you can stream this on twitter clubhouse
and uh stuff about detectives and things
like that they're all it's all over
twitch yeah in fact a lot of people were
uh i don't know if you know that show a
lot of people react to the part of
twitch is like react content like you
react to stuff like maybe somebody
watches this they'll react to it they'll
stream and one of the big big react
things that people was really popular we
should stay in this for a little while
yeah you could stream this yeah live pd
was really popular to react to oh yeah i
wanted to do a show on twitch i wanted
to do live pd but i wanted to do it
globally
on twitch i think it'd be really i l i
think it's super entertaining but then
they do that didn't they do that on i
think this would be better than what
they do on a e like those cops like they
go let's go to new jersey because
high speed chase i did uh
when did she would you call it guest
house or club clubhouse you have to come
up with his idea
yeah awesome but oh [ __ ] i just i turned
it off okay okay did you download it and
let's see also a website as well so you
don't have to it's not just yeah i can
type in your computer or any device
twitch.tv oh my
there you go
there you go okay i got it now it's
downloading uh yeah live pd
one of my favorite shows did you watch
that i've seen it i don't want it
it's all delayed right like they can't
do it live for liability stuff but
and that was really entertaining that's
nice
i enjoyed that stuff but if the wife's
around said i don't like this one but a
lot of people enjoy it see i'm not i'm
not i'm not i've never been a police i
mean it was hard to tell i've never been
a police officer you know
but
uh
you know but it was super entertaining
for me
you know at one point i did want to be a
police officer does perla have uh
interests in the same interests you have
like if you guys were watching twitch
and you were watching uh what's what's
criminal what's crime on there uh
there's some people that do some like
crime shows they like watch the crime
shows then they analyze it oh yeah yeah
that's cool true crime or like that sort
of stuff i have some friends that like
watch like the interrogations
uh oh yeah i've my like youtube
algorithm has started recommending
a lot of yeah he watches all these
interrogations okay so you know
do you know you could be the host of one
of those yeah will you watch uh crippled
shows right yeah and you could come in
and give your expertise because you did
it for so many years you could watch
these things that happen like like real
so you know like a news story comes out
you know how they bring it on you watch
the news the news story comes out they
bring in the professional analyst you
could be your own professional analyst
you can and you can analyze whatever you
wanted and because you come with that
real world expertise you could stream
that and people would watch it let me
tell you something you know a lot of
people think you're full of [ __ ] not on
twitch you they're all 100 percent love
you
yeah yeah
[Music]
he looked at me straight like that
building
whatever you want whatever you want no
so you know what i don't give a [ __ ] uh
gil uh
what do you think let's go uh let's
create a username we sort of go by real
guilt on a lot of stuff yeah real guilt
the real guilt
somebody wrote that uh okay you got to
create your message your password yeah
yeah okay all right
oh no that we just told everybody
where you got to find another george
give me a password what do you think uh
well if you can't announce my password
they'll do this right we can bleep it
out also like
you can change it between now
i'll just make it george
i don't know just simple something you
remember go omg hi omg hi george omg oh
my god oh my god
george o m g
and i did a clubhouse and you're born in
83 right
hey uh um
i did a clubhouse on a cop on on a
stocker case not a couple weeks ago oh
is that what that was about is about it
yeah like an ongoing case or uh
um stalker the night soccer okay oh yeah
and it was a bunch of people asking
questions about it and i talked about it
and
uh what are the best things to follow on
on twitch it depends on what you like i
mean if you like politics you like
politics uh like music and you like
music
yeah
music and choncho
the thing is everybody's different
everybody's got their their what they
like right so the beauty of twitch is
everything that you like is broken down
into categories okay so you can go you
can go to each different category on
twitch as you can probably see as you're
scrolling through your app here if you
like music you want to listen to music
go to go to the music section you'll
find musicians playing music and i think
it's better than like i want to say some
other names but yeah it's it's more
current than more fun i'll show you i
got a guy that i opened for my show
right okay i every every show that i do
i always have a musician that opens
because i i love music too it's my
favorite um
there was a girl was uh this this guy's
a amazing guitar he was one of the dudes
in el chicano this guy right here do you
like it you like i try to play oh yeah
you play guitar guitar podcast
absolutely i saw this dude man i love
this dude yeah
he's so this is i i highlighted this
because he breaks it down here
[Music]
[Laughter]
and let's shut him out what's his name
his name's 24k brown magic
that's his name yeah yeah but but here
wait wait wait wait till he gets into it
yeah wait
you like that girl i like it let's
follow him
you said watch him he he really breaks
this
that's an acoustic he's doing that on an
acoustic he's got a little setup
oh hey man that's well it was me i i
must i told him to tear it up and then
oh yeah is that him
you see here
uh yeah so no but so i bring i bring
musicians on he's not the only one but i
like to bring musicians on because i
like to get the i like to get the show
started with something musical or you
know where do you find the where do you
find them so uh you know all over the
place all over twitch like like how you
would go look for somebody like that
you're interested in yeah and you know
uh
that's how i find them i just i scroll
through the sections i know age this guy
24k brown magic aj
i know him from just
scrolling through this i i i part of my
i've done talent shows like a little
talent like yeah
which i think is uh
still fun yeah they're fun yeah it's
great
and on twitch it's a different feel it's
a different vibe because it's a
different you know it's not like tv it's
it's more personal right all right tell
you what
we're gonna if you would help us we're
gonna do a talent show okay here okay
right now and the winner yeah no isn't
it longer to because this is yeah yeah
but the winner
will receive
and bring him into the studio bring him
in the studio yeah will you help us with
that i will help you with that right
absolutely yeah that way we can see
people and uh and you guys be the judges
and you too okay i'll do it you have to
come back i'll do it yeah i think that's
fun that'd be badass and there's so many
fun and there's so much talent that runs
through the website and they're way
different now like you know listen we
were growing up
you were two kinds of people osmonds or
jackson five you couldn't be both no but
i mean think about when we were kids
like if a kid could sing there's always
that little kid at the border that could
sing [ __ ] i never got a cross sail
[ __ ] 25 feet away there we go never
got across but there wasn't a like the
way they are now like you could see
very few maybe we had one in the family
that could sing or somebody i could sing
and then i think maybe what uh you know
i don't star search maybe and then you
started to see
people younger and then now
[ __ ] bieber man
my daughter 10 years ago
2009 my daughter plays me this thing
bieber was supposed to go to some
house or some party and he got snowed in
and he sent a video and they got on
youtube and everybody started seeing it
and then mine shows me this video and
and i've never heard of them and she's
like go to go to work on monday and see
if you know get that guy on there and i
show jim god rest his soul and jim goes
oh that dudes are like next week but
they were already out they were already
on it yeah because either you know music
or you don't know music that's the thing
and what i tell people today is like a
lot of people will try to go do it the
old you know the old school way move to
la be a server i'm like what are you
doing you got the whole thing is
at your fingertips all of it's at your
fingertips and then a lot of people
don't want to do that because they're
like oh i can't do it that way oh so you
think you can't you can't do it that way
imagine trying to do it the let me stop
you right there yeah okay what he just
said
is
the most important thing i think if
anybody said like
i would have to say right now like where
where are we right now as
entertainers or struggling artist you
don't need to come to los angeles
because it's expensive here it's
dangerous if you're not going to make it
nope there's really it's going to be
very difficult
from where somebody is even if you're
in the comfort of an apartment you move
over here you're not going to have any
friends you're not going to have any
comfort you're always going to be
looking mostly people get ripped off
when they come here but what he said
where if you're wherever because of like
twitch and stuff like that that you
could just do it open up your channel
and they and now there's things for you
to do that's your best shot that's the
that's the best when you when you move
to l.a i mean i've heard second-hand
stories
you know you've got to struggle to
survive and when you're trying to
survive and pursue your dream at the
same time it's almost impossible and so
when i when i started out i said i will
never
ever move to los angeles without an
opportunity to be established there and
so i still don't live here you know and
obviously i i could live here right and
we talked about this earlier i'm going
to probably move down here but it's
because of opportunity that right that
is presented itself that exists now it
exists now right but but i would never
pursue like a you know
you got to be realistic you got to i've
never heard anybody say
not to come out here and everything
you're doing you can do with this like
if somebody can sing they can sing if
they can play they can play literally
right i mean we were we were um we
there's this thing called uh people out
in public you know streaming with their
phones you know
there's a more like uh intricate setup
that that is uh that gives you better
sell signal called an irl backpack so
it's basically like a backpack with
cable modems in it and a camera but it's
just like a gopro camera and we we were
just a university for that yeah we're a
universal student
walking around universal studios with a
gopro camera
and like 50 to 100 000 people watching
and we were just walking around doing
what we were doing and everybody's just
watching us do it and it it's that
simple and everybody you know like i
said when i talk earlier when i talk
about the traditional everybody you know
that's that's hard when you come from a
traditional state of mind that's hard to
understand because you know how
expensive it is to bring in you know how
expensive these shows are you know yeah
it's a different it's but it's a
different approach you know and the
audiences love it all these kids growing
up that's what they want to watch
even if they're not even if they're not
musicians or whatever but they can watch
it and and see people when see
people
that you would think oh there's no way
even like when they show x factor like
uh what's that lady's name that
susan
yeah first of all
your [ __ ] last name is boy
susan laceration i changed it but nobody
you know there's still those things like
on america's got talent where somebody
looks like they can't sing and then they
they do great but this is like they have
that they just 24 hours a day yeah
before the olympics just before the
underdog
before the olympics one of the last
americans got talent they had some kid
he's got to be about 10 years old
and he got out there and he sang his ass
off it was a boy
that guy sounded like a rhythm and blues
singer like
it was awesome and i told my wife i said
i'd pay to go see the kid today yeah
what are those what are those dudes are
those how does how does somebody have
that i mean
born again or was here before you
believe in that stuff
yeah oh like yeah i mean i've actually
read i was just reading stories about
that like some people when they're kids
they like have memories of a past life
like how the [ __ ]
how do you explain that the guy that
does my social media said that his son
said something to him one time
that was so
above a four-year-old yeah that they go
i think my i think my son has something
where
what's the way he'll come up and he'll
say something that you're like there's
no way a four-year-old yeah would say
this is the second lap they've done
studies and they're like man there's no
way they've like done studies to like
validate what these kids have been
saying and it's like they're so real
[ __ ]
it's interesting bieber hit pots and
pans
growing up didn't have money for
uh
drums or anything they play however they
play you give prince bought a guitar he
told me in minneapolis had a crest jj
newberry remember chris yeah and he kept
that with him 50 50
that one that
has a tiger strap like he plays it all
the time
and he said
he told me i go where'd you get this and
he goes oh that's my bad he was
backstage and i just you know when you
hit the all six strings like that and he
goes no you can put it on and i said i
don't know what to put on that and it
said horner horner's the harmonica thing
right so i said what you get because i
you you know it's in purple rain you
know you see it and he's like i did he
goes george i've done everything that
i've ever done on that i could touch my
baby right there done everything i've
ever done musically on that guitar wow
and then he goes i got it out of he said
at jj newberry in minneapolis is fifty
dollars and he goes and the guy came
over
not that he was small but the guy came
over remember they would put the there'd
be one on display and then if you see
the salesman a man can i buy one of
these he goes yeah i gotta get the light
up right back and the rest of them are
up there yeah pulls it down gives it to
him didn't say like let me try it let me
try the other one just gave it down put
it to him in that guitar box and
billions of dollars later yeah this dude
did everything that he did on that
guitar it's amazing because i think a
lot of people think that they've got to
have all this extravagant whether
whatever you're doing whether you're a
musician whether you're a streamer
whatever they always think you got to
have
uh the most extravagant expensive stuff
well i think that
that's another good point too is
people are musical or they're
intellectual or they're artistic
in in ways that nobody else can
understand and sometimes that's kids
you're a kid that that can draw so
cartoon you know mr cartoon the artist
the tattoo artist and all he's a big you
know uh does everything um
he told me when he was 12 that his
friends made him feel
like he was weird for being able to draw
like this is a dude that's a he can draw
at 12. he goes i didn't draw for three
years because those dudes that were my
friends made me feel like i was stupid
because i could draw
and he just got kind of like oh what the
[ __ ] what am i drawing for he goes in
three years later he started drawing but
for three years he didn't draw because
his friends made him feel
weird because they couldn't draw and he
could so they're like hey let's [ __ ]
with him until he stops drawing yeah and
then now look at him he's like
world-renowned a lot of people were like
that in the streaming industry oh yeah a
lot of people were like including me i
wasn't i mean i'm not gonna sit here and
be like oh i was bullied you know but i
had people but if you're wondering how
you would have been bullied yeah right i
think because you have to have the
the
why don't you know the intellect of
being like how did you start your thing
you started your own
show yeah yeah just kind of i mean
a lot of it hap networking is really key
i mean any industry right like i bet if
you guys look back at what you did
or what you're doing it's all about who
you know right is that is that true i
don't know
maybe
when you when you came up i mean
who did you did you you probably met
somebody
that
that kid
2001 i met sandra bullock in august
and in
march of 2002 my first show premiered
and she was my executive producer and
she was
on the show four or five times that if
it wasn't for her
i'd be where everybody wanted me to be
[ __ ] the streets no yeah
but you know
if i hadn't had her i don't know if
anybody would have taken an interest in
somebody and there wasn't
uh like where i could have been funny at
the house or done things like they do
now now they do my material
on tick tock or do impressions of that
dude like that dude does me and they
have millions of followers but they're
they're doing me yeah they take a little
bit of the stand up
do you ever reach out to those people oh
yeah yeah
yeah
he was cool yeah yeah yeah but uh uh how
how does um
because what did you do on clubhouse
clubhouse is audio only right so i got
gil on clubhouse and you what did you
host uh i i didn't host i was a guest
speaker on clubhouse with a cop that
listened to the one i did with you right
and he had asked me if i would do one
with him and it's primarily
writers and people that are into uh
crime stuff
and so we talk about the nightstalker
case everybody's into crime stuff yeah
it was it was not just me but i love
that [ __ ] yeah well i can never watch it
late at night because i'm like forensic
files
like i'm just figure scared
i'm like i'm like sitting here in my in
my house alone in my bed in forensic
files that creepy music and the creepy
guy talking i'm like thinking of all
these new ways i could get murdered i
was watching the [ __ ] zodiac killer
documentary last week
i got scared of [ __ ] turn the lights
on i went to
i was bed scared man yeah because i'm
upstairs there's two ways to get me one
[ __ ] this way and one that way and i
did i was in there as like 3 30 in the
morning and i was like man you know what
i'm [ __ ] getting scared turn it off
turn the lights on and turn the
television off and i don't trust myself
with a gun
you know because i'd probably shoot
somebody that i do on accident what is
it called uh i have a gun too i almost
shot myself because i was i was walking
kind of my house was haunted so i was
walking with it pointed down so right on
the over the shot myself
yeah what do you call it when your
back's to the wall you said you did it
on the on that documentary yeah you do
you what do you call it how are you
doing to make sure nobody comes from you
know
what's it called
you said something was called something
you're just pruning out so if you get
hit
you know you're going to go up against
the wall and slide down but nobody
if you when you go into a place you go
alongside the wall yeah yeah you go in
and clear first guy in
stops and clears
and then everybody else moves around you
you're behind you're clearing him but
you're keeping your back up against war
you don't want anybody to come in from
behind and if you get hit you want to be
able to
lean back into that wall you ever tell
me ever somebody shot at you i've had
somebody shoot at me pearl is a cop
he's a cop birdless mom
and nobody got hit
oh but
it was a you know they come out on the
radio they did an attention to stellar
unit chp in pursuit
northbound forward approaching brooklyn
because that's before it was cesar
chavez so they're coming up forward and
i just happen to be on uh i was
approaching floral i happened to be on
floral
going westbound
and my partner's driving you got a
license you got your lights on sirens no
no we were in an unmarked car we're
wearing these green raid jackets i was
wearing plain clothes games
unmarked car red spotlights
if we needed them
and
so all of a sudden i looked and i said
hey partner guy's coming up behind us
whoa and what he would do is the the
suspect would pull over the curb chp
would get out of the car as soon as he'd
get out of the car the guy would take
off again but he's only driving about
five miles an hour
and i saw him hit a couple of cars and i
said okay parker when he comes up behind
us
pin him in when he gets to the curb
pin him in just park off at an angle in
case chp comes out shooting you know
we're out of their line of fire
so we do that
i go around the front of my car i come
up to the side of the driver's side
first chp officer who happened to be the
book man the guy on the passenger side
of his car comes up sees me what does it
mean to be the bookman that means you're
you're the guy in command that night
okay and you're writing all the paper
all right so did you know that um
he comes out of the car
and he sees me and he says thanks he
knows i'm a cop he knows we're cops hey
thanks a lot
well the guy behind the wheel looks at
me
and it's like fat ass on the line now
he's gonna
pull it and try and
run me over you know i'm off to a side
and i get next to the door and i tell
him i said you do and you're dead
you know don't do it
now whoa at this time
driver chp officer gets out of the car
and i hear somebody say
drop your guns
and i said oh this bubble so has a gun
that i'm not aware of now i'm really
luck my partner comes in
now my partner's next to me but only
he's on the on the trunk of our car
and he's down you got the guy on the
opposite side of the car pointing the
gun so essentially we're not in a
crossfire the angle app but he's
pointing at the driver i'm pointing the
driver my partner pointed the driver
we're going to light this guy up if he
tries to do anything
this guy
says
he says drop your guns oh my god this
first officer yells back at him he says
it's okay
they're sheriffs
i said part of this guy
he's talking about us oh my god and this
guy says i don't know who they are drop
your guns i said all right all right
there it is i threw my gun on the ground
put my hands up in the air my partner
was really pissed because he was using
his own personal gun he put his gun down
on the ground hands are in here once her
hands are in the air it's boom
he shoots
i jump over the car carter gets behind
the car i got another gun strapped on my
leg i pull it out i said it's okay
partner if he shoots again i'll dump him
you know i was calm
he missed us
but this guy
his partner are they trying to hit you
well he was trying to hit me or my
partner what
and
we were downrange he's shooting and then
that guy just starts yelling
you stupid mother [ __ ] what are you
doing used to and the gang members
because of sirens
oh this is [ __ ] beautiful
you know and
then uh
man another cop who would come up
following the pursuit another deputy
said put it out
attention he sell the unit shots fired
and i had to pick up the right now it's
really [ __ ] gonna go off because
shots fired because everybody's pulling
out everybody starts rolling and i just
said
damn
code 4 shots were fired accidental
discharge no further assistance needed
requesting sam continue the sergeant get
him out here so we went out there and a
guy comes up he wants to you know he's
begging for forgiveness i [ __ ] that
guy he said hey
get get away from me partner you better
take care of that guy before these gang
members are going to lynch him you got a
job you know take care of that guy don't
worry about us right now
my partner's pissed off could you hear
it go by or what no i didn't say he he
waited till your guns were down yes and
then he fired at you and then he had the
balls to come up and ask for forgiveness
yeah he
what was his what was his explanation
the guy had been in the streets for 10
days
he was rookie he went through vapor lock
in the analogy when they wrote it up
they said had a 10 10 ton
mack truck come by and sounded its horn
he never would have heard it he just
tunnel vision focus up in the academy oh
my god and during their training
they're teaching these guys up there hey
you're in east l.a back then it was
hardcore you're in east l.a you got to
be careful yet that the danger they'll
they'll kill you they'll shoot you just
as soon as look at you so
the bottom line they got their guy
we went back did he know you guys were
sheriffs do you know you were police
officers not even with that green
windbreaker like two votes
he said all he saw
he said he saw me with a six inch barrel
uh revolver my partner had a boar barrel
gun a big gun
and neither one of us had you know i had
a four inch my partner had a two and a
half inch
then that he had that that's it he never
saw the ray jack and he never saw
anything he was just scared he saw guns
so he ended up getting fired you know
okay
do you think that is one of the reasons
why the streets
with law enforcement are are a little
bit more dangerous that that some people
are on the streets that maybe don't have
the training
uh that they should before they're
released on the streets well no how did
i say that
i get what you're saying i understand
what you i understand what you're saying
but i can't blame it on the training
that they're giving them in the academy
it is more dangerous today than it was
when this happened to me more people
have guns out there today more people
are
willing to shoot at cops they really
don't care they've lost all
respect for any authority not just law
enforcement and they're going to be
they're going to be shooting so you have
to be cognizant of that because if
you're not
then you die and i want to go home
yeah that's that's a situation like
you've never heard of that right no i've
never heard of that i could never
i could never be a cop there was one
time like i said i went on my ride along
and i was interested in police
i was like
21.
so i went on my ride along and i was the
reason i was sitting in the front in the
back front okay front he had me in the
front what what uh what town uh portland
oregon portland pd uh
yeah i think it was portland police i
got nice cars it was in it but it was in
a uh so we
the thing about it is i came and i
showed up in khakis and a button-up
because that's what they told you had to
do and i went on this ride along and i
was thinking you know they'll keep me
safe because
you know i'm gonna but
we gotta call uh
i was right next to him at every call
one time they got a call for like shots
fired gun like discharge or something
like that we came in lights uh
uh like lights and sirens screaming and
the canine unit shows up you know
you know they're all getting there
they're putting on fighting gloves
and i'm like you know you want me to
stay in the car he said no come on i'm
like what and so we're walking into this
like apartment complex building and you
know we're walking up the stairs
somebody kicks open the door the cop
grabs for his gun and i'm just sitting
right here in my
you know
in my button up and and i was like you
know then i realized i can't hey was
that cool that they let him do that no
yeah i'm serious i'm not even i'm not
bullshitting him
just your story yeah i'm just saying
unadulterated [ __ ] he never should
have had you with that car yeah who gets
shot first i think he does well either
one of them gets shot if he gets hurt
while he's in there but if a guy's
running he looks back and he sees a cop
and then another guy
i'm going i'm sure i'm sure everybody's
on twitch yeah
i wasn't on twitch yeah
i mean it was interesting is it is an
interesting story but like at the same
time i was curious i was like why the
hell am i and we were i told geraldo
rivera who was riding around with me and
doing the
nightline special and he wanted to show
the guys from garrity up in the hill
that he wasn't afraid of him because
they had threatened him hey don't come
back here sarvato you come back here
we'll take care of business and they
would have right so well if they had the
chance they would have so i stopped my
car getting ready and he got out of the
car out of the car before i could do
anything and he went running up the
stairs he's called the chica lomachika
and he went running up the stairs so now
i got to go running up because he's my
ride along
i'm responsible you have video of that
no no because cameras weren't rolling
you mean harald revere did something
that he didn't video changed
after he did
and uh
so we we went up there
and i said okay let's go we got back in
the car and i just turned around i told
him if you ever
run away from my car again [ __ ] i'll
take you right back into the station get
your ass out of my car i don't care
who's liable for him i am yeah okay
another thing we did uh while we were on
the ride-along
is he said you know i can pull over
anybody i want oh man what he told me he
said
he said
uh you just got to find a reason for it
and uh he's like yeah you see that car
behind us they're driving through a
you know
thing and then uh
i said okay and he never gave anybody
tickets but
that's what we did a lot of people you
can't pull over anything you you that
that's not a bad speech no no no i can
pull out you you can find you're doing
something wrong right everything
everything goes on this this magic word
the kids throw out they don't know what
it means probable cause yes so you stop
a car for a vehicle called violation you
get up there you smell you see
and that's all the problem they don't
need he never and he never gave a ticket
but we did uh
uh most of the day we were stuck with
somebody that put their car in a ditch
we missed a bank robbery we missed all
sorts of fun stuff
but uh but they do that right they do
bank robberies or what who shows up at a
bank robbery cops everybody knows yeah
bank robberies they end up being the
best i won't say most
some get investigated by the fbi because
it's they're they're fdic uh
insured so it's federal
you know they're investing their federal
federal money so fbi comes let me tell
you a story of this bank rapper told me
this guy robert passed away a guy right
there we did it we did when i had my
talk show we did a thing at alcatraz so
we went to alcatraz in the middle of the
night trying to see who was hunter
whatever so robert forget his last name
gave us a tour he did five years there
so back then he said in the early 70s
like there would be um
like robbery squads where somebody was
the driver
and somebody
had gave the note and somebody was three
of them and somebody watched the door
right
so
girl guy him
he was the guy that went in there so
they go to a crocker bank in la
and they rob the bank to get away with
it they go to a safe house they count
the money they separate you know people
would put like criminal things together
like little mob things you know so
he stays here
and the other two people men and the
woman go to new orleans and they're
sitting in a bar drinking
talking
getting loud they got money they're
talking about how they robbed a bank in
l.a and got away with it one of the
dudes at the bar is a cop
but he's you know he's off duty so he
you know he listens to him and buys them
beer then he goes back calls lapd and
said hey did you guys have like a
robbery that wasn't uh you don't ever
discover like a crazy goes yeah
i can do flies out there they they take
them they roll over on robert roberts
said he was on ventura boulevard at a
like back in the 70s like maybe 60s 50s
maybe that they did like um
you know after church you go have like a
malt and ice cream and stuff you know
like a family and he said he was sitting
here his girlfriend had a had a
son and they were sitting across from
him like this and he said he looked
outside and he goes it just looked too
still
because i looked outside and
i thought
wow it looks kind of still out there
dude slid in right here
uh detective goes let's go
got him
uh he didn't say anything to them they
were like their mouth was open took him
to leavenworth he was an escape he was i
was in the skate backer to skate from
anything and he was going to escape from
leavenworth but the cop forgot to turn
the key at the last one of the last
places and he had to open the door and
turn the king when he opened the door he
was on top of the [ __ ] wall there
they go and then they go the cops the
the judge said i'm gonna send you to a
place where you can't escape he did five
years in alcatraz oh wow
you know the the the criminal mind is
incredible you know i had i had a case
it was like a sam's club a costco was in
hawthorne it's a big
uh store like that
and in working the investigation we
found out
that mr big
that's you
you were calling the shots
so you would call up grant right he's
the trash i know the guy's to get the
okay he's the trash man so what he would
do
is the trash man would go remember
before he used to have these carbon
on credit cards yeah carpets would go
out well he'd go through the trash how
[ __ ] dangerous was that man
they go hey thanks for coming by they go
like this to your thing and they have
that carbon carbon goes in the trash the
trash man would go
through it
find as many
as many carbons as he could
he would take him
he would take him down to george and
he'd go over there and he'd look at him
he had a machine because cards they
don't care about your name all they care
about is the number that's on there
so back then yeah the number was on
there if it was good for ten thousand
dollars okay we'll keep this
and he gets paid 50 bucks for every
clean every one he brought in
so but he doesn't know
anybody else other than you he has no
idea he gives you the carbons you give
them to him he runs them they're clean
okay now you contact me
and you tell me
okay
here's uh here's a credit card because
now what you do is you know
your man back there
he makes plastic
so
here's the numbers put it on it put his
name on there so now there's they could
make a card that could make like
mastercards or whatever they were using
american express yeah american express
now with my name on it knowing that it's
good for ten thousand dollars at least
and you changed they could just change
the name they give them makeup on one
buy
so
give it to me i would go rent a car
go to hertz
let me rent a car they can't report that
car stolen for 30 days
so here here's the card it's good
he says then i want you to get the car
go park it tell them exactly where to
park it leave the keys underneath the
floor mat
walk away never go back to the car
then he would get another guy
and he'd say okay
get three of your homies
here's what you're gonna do you go in
you hit the store
i want fifty thousand you can have
anything after that wow
and nobody knew
anybody else it was anybody else that
was going on
they did it they did the store they got
a shootout and
somebody was hired just to go sit at the
store in case there was a problem they
could follow the getaway in case there
was a chase they followed getaway car
happened at hawthorne we found the car
parked in englewood close by
it's always rental we ended up working
with uh who are the guys at the stole uh
secret service
and because
they were into this [ __ ] and we found
out
that
these guys were going and you said
in another state they were doing uh
jewelry you know smash and grabs they'd
get on a plane here
in lax
go to chicago do a smash and grab turn
around get on the plane and come back to
l.a nobody'd ever catch amazing you know
they got away with it and you know where
mr big was living
he was living in the pool and he was
living in bisca
he was living in biscaloo center he was
an inmate oh man what running everything
from the jails
you know it was
uh it was incredible how many of these
things how many bank robberies were how
much of this goes unsolved i don't know
i didn't work background i don't think
they do it i just work murderers
how many murders go on
a lot of them now because of the ability
mobility
and uh you'd think now it'd be the
opposite right because with technology
and everything it's it was easier back
then to
yeah it was they weren't as mobile
and now but also
there wasn't uh you know more
territorial back in the day when i first
got there somebody killed you it was
normally
somebody you knew yeah
you know now
with mobility and transit they go out
all over the place it could be from
somebody from the travel to sure yeah
yeah so you met you i just don't know
and they do fortunately the guys that
are not so smart talk about stuff even
in code but they talk about on social
media yeah so you look at social media
you do everything you can oh yeah that's
i was being harassed one time and uh you
know the fbi helped me out then i was
harassed another time and they said well
bring your phone down here and we'll
dump it i said what's that that we'll
take everything that's in there and then
we'll take the messages that you know
are bothersome but we'll look at all
your messages that [ __ ] you don't worry
about i can live
i can live like that nobody
hey they looked at my phone when i was
married the fbi and look at that
i made it 17 years i can make it the
rest of my life
[ __ ] that you don't want anybody dumping
your phone and seeing all that [ __ ] oh
no god no no but in uh if now because
you know they have that like where the
money blows up they don't they're not
really
robbing banks anymore because they know
how much it's due like they don't do too
many bankers they're not getting that
much money out of things cracking uh how
do they steal from how would they steal
from breaking into accounts and stuff
like that like knowing accounts oh now
electronically every everybody's hacking
you fraud yeah
you know get phished or something like
yeah or like fake phone call like
fishing foot calls and stuff like oh you
won this or something like that right
like what are they doing sometimes they
send you an email there's another
helpful tip
that says like maybe it's apple and
they're redoing their thing and you got
to put never do that and never open [ __ ]
never open it delete it don't even click
the link apple's not even apple doesn't
need to do that no and that's how i know
somebody they got oh yeah and they'll
text you too
that's right they'll text you guys
don't touch [ __ ] don't
don't open it don't respond don't
voicemail scam that's been going around
lately where it's like you know we're
contacting you about like your vehicle's
extended warranty oh yeah or something
like that that's fun same thing it's
like the irs you went out years yeah you
also you haven't said my name you
haven't said my vehicle you have more do
you have more protection on there's a
way to protect your phone from
that stuff i mean
there is probably i don't have any more
protection in the do you i mean do you
have any more protection than the
average prescription or something i
don't know i mean
i mean i got password a bunch of
different passwords that are long and i
don't even know my passwords to be
honest with you two-factor you know
two-factor but you can't do two-factor
on your phone so you gotta use like a
usb uh like uh like yeah encrypted uh
little code that generates but you don't
wanna use your phone because then you
can people could hijack your uh
your uh what do you call it your uh
your phone like your messages did you oh
if your phone number
that was before stuff how did were
people dealing now with like um
well there was no there wasn't any
phones no you didn't this this was not a
problem
when i was working yeah see
i i mean i didn't have a cell phone
until i was i'm 27. i didn't have one
until i was
uh
it's them right now hey speaking of
[ __ ] spammers yeah there you go as we
speak
well they don't
no
um let's open it up and let's fire this
fire went off in there
but right so so they'll get you by is
there any way like they have cars that
go by that they can read your can they
reach i've heard i've heard people i've
heard people like uh dr they can uh with
credit cards theft they've like gone by
like you know because cards are
contactless now
and so they can like use that
hijack that same technology and walk by
somebody and walk by their wallet and
then pick up their car details i don't
know about that i mean it's one of those
things where i've heard about but
there's so many of those that end up you
hear about but end up not being and you
don't know but the biggest thing is the
database leaks so what these hackers
will do is they'll hack major databases
and you don't even know sometimes and
you put your credit card details on like
i don't know whatever website you know
uh and sure and then they they get the
whole database and then you know i'm
sure you've had we've all had like
situations where we get a call like did
you purchase this somebody tried to
write 300 worth of birkenstocks right on
my credit card i said sometimes you get
away with it yeah yeah yeah sometimes
something where they were using my my
card and buying stuff i wasn't liable
for it but you can see that yeah
somebody was snatching my yeah my number
and they got it they got it from a just
a database yeah the debate databases
just that people hack into it what is
the what is
what's the age of twitter like this all
you do is
so you can be is it safe for people
uh yeah it's safe i mean of course it's
the internet so you gotta be careful but
there's a minimum you have to be you
can't be under the age of 13 to be on
twitch you can't that 13 is the minimum
age to watch twitch consume twitch right
there's additional filters for like 18
years or older but there's no age limit
on twitch i mean you could be there's
people that are in there that are very
old there's something for everybody
there right absolutely so you got to
like you know like not all the content
is going to be appropriate for a 13 year
old right so like what they're like what
do they have like i mean there's no like
hot tub streamers yeah hot tub i mean
like you have adult performers that'll
stream on twitch they won't stream their
adult performances but they'll be adult
performers like you know good friend of
mine mia malkova is a big you know uh
a bit of a thing for people for like
porn stars in particular to find a sort
of second life yeah because they they
want to they want to they want to have a
more personal connection
you know with their audience it shows
them beyond their their their their
acting career right
you know so and and so that's that
that's what happens on twitch you get
you know a wide variety uh but you know
what's interesting the porn stars are
actually some of the cleanest uh
content creators on the platform because
what are they doing well like i don't
know about cooking or playing games yeah
you know playing games yeah and you're
watching them and you're watching them
do it right yeah or or like he said
there's this thing called hot tub
people's girls some some girls some guys
sit in the hot tub it's like a recent
phenomenon and i'm not super well worked
but i just know like it was a thing
where people started doing like streams
essentially the equivalent like a
podcast sometimes but like they're in
hot tubs it's hot girls wearing bikinis
stuff yeah and they're sitting in a hot
tub and they're just how do we moderate
this but they're circumventing the rules
right because they're hey they're in a
hot tub they're in a bikini they're not
being sexual are they flashing uh are
they are they no flashing no no
as soon as you show your boobs it's over
right but like you can you can still
kind of you know
be suggested but can somebody lure you
into a uh a twitch room that like nobody
else can see it's all public so you're
all broadcasting publicly are you
looking gil
yeah are you trying to find their well
they're it's telling me they're going to
send me a cochinos.com that's my
verification code email
so yeah so you uh do that afterwards too
what do you like let's see what what do
you like um
you could you're listening let's say vfw
for the pg
so much of it too and you know austin's
representative of this is it's
personality driven like the content is
good yes but like you know in a world
where there's just a million different
everything's like you tend to just feel
someone you like
and maybe they do music maybe they do
whatever let's see like irl like you get
a lot of people
oh hey podcasts you like podcasts we're
on a podcast right
a legend you could relive vietnam over
here man
i'm not sure that anybody really is an
ad or are you watching a it wasn't that
hey but but um
so there's a talk shows and podcast
section right you imagine if they were
streaming in vietnam like nobody holy
[ __ ]
crazy nuts they do that now with the
guys have uh
body cameras and stuff and you see that
should happen yeah to them yeah that's
crazy right
i mean i don't know about it like
you can find you can find anything on
the internet you ever heard of what do
they call that rule no that's for porn
yeah yeah what is that
rule 34 is the rule that if you can
think it there's porn of it
oh that's true
anything you can think of i'm talking
anything you can think of
there's porn of it yo you don't you
don't look at porn do you no no don't
start man cause this is the hardest
thing to [ __ ] stop doing i i didn't i
didn't for a long time
and um i'm just playing golf with this
guy and this guy's like hey man you
never check out like
red tube or whatever the [ __ ] that is
i'm like what is that yeah and then uh i
checked it out and i think everybody
watches the dark day i don't know man
everybody does right
i spend most of my time on the church
channel
hey put the microphone down so you can
see you kill skills
what are you checking out i'm just
trying to get my uh
twitch account all right oh yeah when we
get you hooked up we can go now go ahead
go ahead go ahead and go for it go ahead
let them do it yeah they're like keeping
up occupied that's what i think it's one
of those things
to play with everybody watches people
yeah everybody everybody masturbates but
even women do don't let them tell you
that they don't
they do use the facts everybody does
which is so interesting how taboo it is
because everybody does it's one of the
so interesting it's so fascinating to me
i mean how's it so taboo how does it
change um if you're dating somebody
and you're both watching porn does it
make you deviant like
when we came up when we grew up yeah we
would say that
you wouldn't do that because then that
per other person would be like oh you
look a little bit like sleazy yeah right
which is which is all those things are
kind of out the window now where he's
never tried marijuana because he said
when he was a sheriff it was a felony
yeah and now it's not yeah and he can't
get past
that nor could i like i grew up around
none of us are really big smokers but
you know eat a little bit but rarely
smoke or sometimes people say you sleep
better with it but to me
i'm like him like i can't get past the
fact that
if you can use it for good yeah and not
for you know because and it just feels
strong my parents same thing i mean my
dad's a lifelong you know marijuana user
but he still can't get past the fact
that he doesn't have to hide it anymore
right right so it's it's a generational
thing yeah and then i get it it's also
state to state because there's people my
age in other states i have conversations
with and they're like whoa and i'm like
whoa chill flame yeah it's not just weed
you know in new mexico it's legal then
in el paso it's not illegal yeah so last
week i went over there and somebody goes
i just go to i just go to new mexico and
buy it and bring it across because
there's no border yeah
yeah oh yeah funnily enough i remember
for me like because i i grew up i was
very you know the dare programs worked
for oh yeah it was very anti-drug yeah
and it was like you've never been in
trouble you never got arrested or
anything no no but i mean in part
because they put the fear of god in me
especially with him i don't think so and
like one of those dudes
um
but it was it was joe rogan smoking weed
on his podcast they really started like
oh this is okay he's doing in public
yeah he's okay yeah he's fine and that
was one of the first things that sort of
got me towards accepting it and
obviously society has changed but like
that truly and i hate to hide because i
i smoke weed i don't smoke i eat it
every day
they say smoking is not the best way to
take it it's better to eat yeah so i eat
it i eat it once a day towards the end
of the day when my day's over i eat it
and i just chill out and it helps me
sleep you know
what do you what do you eat like like a
gummy or like a gummy yeah like the the
the these gummies i go uh i just get
them they're like in a little container
think you so you let you so you let's
talk about that yeah you
you take one it's indigo put you down
right so you take it you turn the tv off
or you're watching and you just fade out
so it's sort of like it it takes a while
to hit you have you taken them before
yeah okay so you know how i see i've
seen one with george's face on the on
the on the on the packaging
do you have something i don't know
i'll have some in the car i'll eat some
i have some in the car i'll i'll take
some
i got a lot i got a lot of uh
i got a lot of edibles at the house yeah
it's good but you got to be careful
where do you live uh oregon
when you come back dude you're not
looking out here yeah i'm gonna bring
them to you huh how long are you out
here i'll be here for four days okay
we'll be here okay i'll catch you
this company wouldn't
but also but also is there a uh
is there an ikea of weed is there like
an apple of weed that's something that
there's not right there's a million
there's there's a bunch i mean like when
you said apple of wheat i think med men
because they have they have like stores
with uh you know very fancy storefronts
very curated sort of experience um but
there's also you know there's it runs
the gamut from you have the names
backwards on your phone yeah okay all
right i'm dyslexic can i text can i text
yeah yeah of course
but um but yeah but there's all sorts of
uh also well that little pipe that i was
hitting last week what was it what was
it bliss did i say bliss oh the uh the
vapes
those were um
i was texting myself
so so those yeah the doses but that i
felt better with that thing i was doing
last week
it's great yeah a lot of people love i'm
officially on twitch now i'm in hey
welcome welcome
he did it
when's your first stream
next week
he did it all official yeah there you go
you got it official you got you what do
you got going on this what are you doing
this week
let's get a stream up doctor tomorrow
stream the colonoscopy oh there you go
hey there's people that stream their
colonoscopy yeah hey it's medical right
you know once you stream the last one
eighth of your dirty cool away yeah
you know honestly i'm dead serious i'm
dead serious that's one part of twitch
that's never existed is like a live
surgery
they they i can't you kind of wonder
what sort of like hypnosis
i mean i can't imagine there's anything
but there's not they're not doing
autopsies you know uh no but that'd be
kind of cool that'd be interesting
everyone want to go to autopsy
but for educational purposes no i think
honestly it'd be kind of interesting um
when you when you would
how's this for detective work so
i don't think they do it now right
detectives don't do it now do what go to
an autopsy yeah they still do it yes so
so if you're if you're working on a
murder
you would go to the autopsy of the
person that was murdered that's crazy
and then you would go there and try to
do what to say
well just to make sure that all the
information is correct simple version i
had a trainee a new new partner
and
this one doctor i used to hate going to
his because he would like to get you
there he'd like to show you his
expertise so he wants to get there and
charting the body
well you chart the body you draw it out
and you look it up with every mark on
the butt i didn't give a [ __ ] about that
stuff
i just want to be there for hey let's do
the cuts just talk about that he's
trying to get his information out yeah
so
i got that and i told the desk i said i
know the doctor make sure i don't want
to get there when he's charting what
time is he going to start cutting that's
what time i want to be there yeah
because he would do the whole big show
and everything and i so he called me i
said okay he said he's going to start
cutting here
so i went there
and the guy was starting to chart
ah and so i said forget it so i'm over
here watching somebody else's autopsy my
partner comes over and says
uh doctor said that's a great one on the
head
and i said he doesn't have no grey's
wound on the head
he says well yeah he does and i said i'm
telling he didn't have a gray's wound on
the head and said well the doctor said i
said let's go over there and i looked at
the doctor i said doc he doesn't have a
graze wound on his head i said he got
shot
he stepped on the gas he drove for about
a half block hit a pole his head went
right into the rear view mirror that's
where he got a jagged cut right there
where he hit his head on the mirror
it's not a grey's wound he says ah that
explains why it's jag and why it's like
this so stuff like that
you have to be there to verify ah that
makes sense because i was wondering i
was like why the hell do you got to be
there yeah and plus you want to learn
from the autopsy
what position the body was in which shot
was first what was the trajectory he's
got a system so there's a there's a lot
to learn is that that's gnarly it must
be like no not at all no very used to it
well you you get used to it but it's
very it's very scientific but it's very
it's knowledge you're it's fascinating
to me to see what your body looks like
on the inside and what it does well we
already know what yours looks like on
the inside
smell a little porthole that you didn't
put some dicks on here the world will
find out you gotta disconnect from that
you know like you you can't you gotta
you gotta remove yourself from the you
know well just like they're not
squeamish
a gynecologist when he's looking
examining a lady he's not breathing
heavy no it's all scientific
professional now get him out of that go
get a couple of pops now he goes out
with his girlfriend yeah he's going to
be breathing heavy for a different
perspective exactly
so when i'm doing that
blood guts and gore it's all very
scientific okay let's say that you
worked at kfc and all of a sudden you
would you wouldn't eat any chicken
because you work at kfc so let's say
you're a gynecologist and you're looking
at choncho for 20 years do you go home
and are you still excited to see a wing
as you would if you were working i can't
wait to eat
because you know at some point you ain't
kicking me out of kfc
you know you're pretty you're pretty
well adjusted for being
the job that the life that you've had i
think you're in the war and
going and being that guy you really are
respect i could never i could never
there's one thing i could never do i
could never go to war i could never be a
cop
why
oh do i be the shittiest cop i'm like
i'd shoot
when you were when you were young you
wanted to what do you want that's a good
reason i want to be a pilot commercial
i wish i could have been a buyer that's
one thing i yeah you just wanna be a
commercial airline i used to play this
game flight simulator and i would get
these this software that would could you
could you learn on that yeah no so the
thing is this is interesting right so i
used to i used to go find like the the
software that they would use planes that
were identical to the real thing
and they would be
identical to like faa sort of like
approved sort of planes and i'd put them
on my computer and i'd fly it and i'd
have all these add-ons that would
simulate the world around me to be
realistic
uh visibility everything and uh i i do
these flights and there'll be real
flights and i copy what's happening in
the real world so i go on online i'd
look up the flight plans i'd have my
charts i'd have my checklist and i'd be
able to do the thing and so like fast
forward many years later like to a
couple years ago
i my friend a friend of mine had this
full motion
seven thirty seven simulators like in
his apartment in manhattan just dan was
loaded and it looked like it was like a
right yeah it was real it was like it
had the boeing uh what they call it like
the boeing um package so like boeing
like sells these packages to these
simulators to make them realistic and
stimulate all the movements and wouldn't
you believe i sat in that thing and i
landed i landed that thing are you
flying because i knew i reckon because
737 was one of the planes i used to
always love to fly on the simulator and
so i knew of course there's some things
i forgot but generally speaking it's
like riding a bike you kind of have to
you kind of have to because when you're
flying when you're playing on your
computer when you're playing on your
computer it's a little different like
for how it feels but that guy had it
where you're sitting in oh yeah you're
in the cockpit of a seven so i always
say if there were two pilots and they
died and i was on a plane
you know they'd be like ladies and
gentlemen everybody
you know that would be how can anybody
yeah
you ever been on a plane where they call
a doctor no i have yeah i've i've given
cpr on a plane
and with my partner frank and i both you
know the guy was having a heart attack
right there we took care of business did
he did he make it well he made it out of
the plane he was still alive when they
took him away once he got him out of the
away from the plane and at the airport
would you become a pilot
i i still have a passion for it but
what's crazy about it is i'm afraid of
i'm i get scared during flight sometimes
when it starts shaking a little bit and
i know what's going on and i'm still i
don't know well you said yourself you're
a control guy you're not in control i
need to be in control of the like of the
of the if i was in the cockpit i
wouldn't be nervous because i know what
was going on right but see when you're
when you don't have the instruments in
front of you you're just you just feel
and that's it and so i'm on on on planes
i'm always on my phone looking at the
altitude the speed everything okay we're
good you know i guess
that was one of my dreams they teach you
how to on a flight simulator when you
before you go to vietnam and your crew
chief
you you're going to learn how to fly
because and then when you get to vietnam
they give you stick time when
upon flights comes up
yeah
they call sick time because
if they get hit somebody's got to fly
this bad boy or you're all going to die
yeah so there's
emergency uh
release button so chair can tilt bag you
could jump in and i love flying
and i love flying a helicopter so
in the army if did you fly a helicopter
yeah well i didn't i didn't fly as a
regular pilot but you but i learned how
to fly and then when they sent you to
when i went to germany
on the general's helicopter the general
was in it i was crew chief if the bird
went up without the general they were
short on pilots so i'd sit in the peter
pilot i'd be co-pilot
uh for them and it would i i love flying
when i'm in vietnam
they had a deal
i agreed i would they would send me back
from vietnam i hadn't finished my tour
they'd send me back early from vietnam
go to flight school and all i had to do
was give them four years upon graduating
flight school
and it was all worth that i wanted to
fly so goddamn bad and i loved it i
loved
i loved dylan you didn't do it
because the guys that i was with in gun
ships they got in a big old brawl they
got drunk they got a great bicycle fight
the company commander wrote a
uh a memo in red ink to my company to my
platoon leader said your hooligans have
done it again they got drunk they made
fools of themselves
everybody's restricted to their own
hooches
and i'm sitting there well i wasn't
there i wasn't part of the fight i saw
the company commander i said excuse me
major fraker
i said what does this do to me leaving
and going back to flight school and he
says young man
he says you're not getting out of here
early unless it's in a pine box now get
out of here
you know so
everything was pulled didn't get to go
you know what i think and i would have
loved it i think those dudes saved your
life well they maybe i think i think
that happened for a reason
to save your life and especially i loved
because
it was i can't do helicopters they were
they were dangerous and it was it was
tough it was hazard but i wanted to fly
and so when i came on the sheriff's
department i wanted to fly they want to
do they used to take their pilots right
from deputies
because they didn't want pilots that had
already flown before
unless they needed one right now because
the fly man yeah i was going to say some
police but
they they stopped you from flying yeah
so i wanted to do it i got
east l.a i got stuck there for a while
my partner had gone through the academy
he used to fly for twa and he used to
fly
uh marine jets
and so he put in they took him over to
arrow bureau
one day years later i'm at homicide he's
flying
he had to fly me up to uh
san jose
on a case need to go do a quick
interview over there
he flies me up there we're on the uh
fixed wing we're long time friends and
then so we're on we're on the uh
we're on a runway getting ready to take
off he's hey you want one take off
i said yeah he says you got it you got
the control oh my god so there we go
and i've got it and then pulled back he
said we're ready we'll pull back take
off and this is bitching i said oh [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] although you can't see
over i can't see over the nose you can't
see over the nose no no when you're
going up like you couldn't see over the
nose just make sure no other plates are
around me he got off he took over again
we're flying we get there we land i go
take our business he waits for me at the
uh airport i get back says okay let's go
get in the plane he's flying me back
john bickel
and john bickle said there's something
called half moon rock or something over
yosemite
and it's
famous
and he says hey gil you ever seen half
moon rock or half moon bay whatever
halftime maybe maybe half dome
so you ever seen happiness i'm a [ __ ]
latino get some [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody
gets it wrong you see that uh the statue
of hilarity
what is that uh so say we always get the
words wrong yeah so it was it was some
kind of half so he said okay so i'll
take you by we went up there and he said
well there it is i said what it looks
like a [ __ ] cliff
and he just like
you know find a biscuit
he said the last time i treat it no try
to show you anything
and he turned around and i didn't see
any more
and he told me i said you know i love
this john i said there's only one place
i'd leave homicide bureau and that would
be to go to arab or if i could fly and
he says you know there's only one job
i'd leave arrow bureau for that's the
worst homicide he says unfortunately for
us
i'm not a good investigator and you're
even worse as a pilot
but i don't know man i mean it's it's
something to say to be up there like the
ocean i lived in hawaii in the ocean is
very powerful a lot of respect for the
ocean i wouldn't try to beat my own
uh but also in the air you know that
that yeah and i don't have the with i
guess all the frequencies and stuff like
that but you know jfk junior was not
somebody asked to go with him and he
said i'm going alone but he lost the
horizon he couldn't fly at night well
yeah you know it's crazy when you i mean
even now when you go over the atlantic
or the pacific there's no radar out
there they they have a they have a they
have a they have to report their
location so pilots when they when when
planes fly across the atlantic pacific
whatever uh the pilots will every in
every interval of their journey they
will report to a radio
their location they'll do like a report
and then that's how they'll track them
across the ocean but there's no radar at
a certain point um but one thing is a
lot of people think that you when you're
flying out in the middle of the ocean
like if you what happens if you your
engine's gone yeah well planes are
actually when you fly like over the
atlantic i mean you're flying north over
greenland you're actually within a
regional district you can gl those
things are just gliders at the end of
the day if you lose all engines it your
cruise out there you know you're just a
glider you know you they can they can
there's been stories where planes have
lost all engines and they just glided
safely into their have you ever been on
a plane that had a near miss or anything
that remotely like an accident no i got
the [ __ ] scared out of me flying on the
way to germany we were out of new jersey
and
we got a military plane yeah no it was a
civilian but it was all military it was
a charter flight united it was world
airways oh world airways world airways
and our flight was delayed mechanical
problems
and
we financial that's already telling you
so we get on a plane we take off we get
ready to take off you know how they pull
power at the end before they take off
you know get that engine built up and
the goddamn plane just starts shaking
that's jesus so we take off and i i love
flying
he takes off
and we start gaining altitude all of a
sudden he cuts back on the engine then
we give a sharp bank
and some of the oxygen masks fell down
oh [ __ ] and i said holy [ __ ] this is it
we're going down you just took off
though yeah we had just taken off and
then all of a sudden impulse power he
strains out
and he just said ladies and gentlemen
sorry for the problem he says uh the
mechanical problem prior to takeoff was
some of these oscillating masks were not
staying inside there was something that
was triggering him off oh
and i talked to john bickel john bickle
says i've flown out of the airport many
a dime he says they have a uh
sound you know you you give engines all
they but you get over the city and you
got to cut back noise abatement noise
abatement yeah he says so you cut back
that's why they go up so there was
nothing wrong yeah just everything
happened at the same time and scared the
beast it's not it's not a good feeling
because even out of lax sometimes you
they'll pull it back uh real real
quickly uh depending on where you're
going you know and it when you're there
when you're doing that round for the
first time it's a little scary like wait
aren't we supposed to be going up but
you're in the air like what yeah you're
the only talent should take that value
the only time i ever get the only time i
ever get concerned
one time when i was in uh vietnam
we you know there's ifr you know yeah
yeah you you fly
fly right yeah yeah flying instrument
and
we were socked in we were you couldn't
see and these rotors are kicking
everything around every which way one
pilot says you take over controls and
get vertigo you could not tell couldn't
do it which way was up which way was
down
and i was scared to death and just like
the commercial
we get over he's following and just
before we get to the camp hallway or our
air base
it cleared up enough so now we can see
we have visuals and the guy was talking
us in but he was reading the
was he reading the instruments he was
reading and listening the radio the
towers had us they still had us on radar
they had us coming in and they were
guiding us in but it was it was scary so
now even in big jets with all the
technology they have
we're coming in i don't care where i'm
coming in lax you come in sometimes you
got to fly through the clouds to get in
when i'm in and i can't see
i just rather close the windows i don't
want to look outside yeah there was that
big plane that took off like some big
super jumbo max plane that if it was
flying on its own like it just
oh yeah
i mean they they all they're no auto
takeoff but there's al all auto land
full out of land these planes are so
sophisticated they'll flare and
everything for you in the land
uh
it's pretty incredible you don't need to
be able to see i was coming back from
vegas on southwest this was like in the
early 90s and all of a sudden our plane
went like this like whoa and i mean
literally you
you're like sideways like that like
quick yeah and the ev you know people
were screaming and [ __ ] people just
just all of a sudden coming in and then
a sharp beer
and they said oh you know sorry about
that and then i'm reading usa today a
couple days later and it said that two
southwest planes almost hate each other
missed each other by a thousand feet i
said oh what flight number was that i
went and found my ticket i was on that
flight oh [ __ ] thousand feet was it
while you were about to left into
burbank oh man [ __ ] thousand thousand
feet
i see the results of what happened i
worked for three days out in cerritos
when they had the
mexico
horrible [ __ ] it was a plane crash
august 31st night
two private airline private uh plane
hit iro mexico 85 passengers yeah dude
flying over the cerritos right into the
neighborhood like fell into this it
looked like a bomb atlanta you ever
heard you ever heard of what they got in
those planes to prevent that kind of
stuff so they got each plane is equipped
with something called tcas it's called
traffic collision avoidance system in
each plane they these these systems work
uh to if there's going to be a collision
it'll tell one to ascend and the other
to descend and they'll communicate with
one another they didn't have that for
private plane it wasn't mandatory
privately
so there was a crash where the
the air traffic controller there was a
collision over i think it was in europe
somewhere there was a crash where the
air traffic controller told the pilots
one thing and then t cass was telling
them the other one so one pilot but
you're always supposed to listen to the
tcas you're never that's the what you
default to and one pilot listened to the
air traffic controller the other
listened to tcas and they descended
right into each other wow and uh it was
catastrophic but that's what they so
there's always backup so you're not just
relying exclusively on air traffic
control
and even if you're not about to collide
the little radar shows all the traffic
around you so you got to show all the
traffic around
so
it's so safe but conventionally in my
head i can't think like i would be able
to do it you have to be a certain i
think you have to be of a certain type
well you had it
when i was when i went that you would
like to fly like something yeah you
can't take somebody that doesn't want to
fly
and then say hey you have an opportunity
to be a pilot it's like well you know
i'm kind of not into flying yeah i have
a friend who's a pilot he was like one
time you have to look like try it try it
out for a second like no thanks
i held it for a second i'm like don't
like be in control of this nope yep the
uh yeah it's scary when i went and did
the uh what about a year and a half ago
i went to
spend uh
some days with the
military or the navy on
the uss harry truman
so we did a show in there but i talked
to some you know i talked to some pilots
and those dudes were saying like
we're you know
because they they do maneuvers like
every day like so they're training and
you know so i go so there's a guy who
goes oh no you know
you know we're hoping to get into into
battle because that's what we live for
yeah like to go up there and fight it
out yeah
[ __ ] this dude is like that's what
you're trying to look like a tall
[ __ ] beautiful like hey yeah
why do i give you a kiss before i leave
but they look like a pilot because
because they have to [ __ ] sit at some
little ass [ __ ] thing in there i went
to uh where the blue what is it the
angels the air force oh i thought you
said blue yeah
dudes that could drive their homes the
air force super pilot that
are they the blue angels i don't know
yeah yeah yeah yeah they do the
maneuvers yeah all the air shows they do
all of them yes yeah well i was in vegas
and a buddy of mine who used to be a
part of that wing with the air force now
out of the air force took me down for a
tour and i got up and looked inside one
of those planes there ain't no way in
hell i'd fit in one of those planes
yes you know what would they do if they
push in would they take you to the
beginning it'd be like a 10 pound
chorizo and a
yeah but those guys
they had it all and everything's there
you know when you get in there yeah the
ejection the
the thing you pull back to fire i'm not
a male chauvinist but i'm more
fascinated with the women that are
flying jets now
you know they get out there and they
want to jump into combat just like
everybody else and it's
more power to them and personally i love
to fly but i'd really rather stick to
helicopters so yeah i'm afraid i'm
afraid i'm the opposite see i can't i'm
afraid of helicopters
you know it's scary the idea of being
hovering with the you know and not
having if that blade stops
i can't really you can auto rotate down
you're not gliding yeah you go down auto
rotate now do you wait do you crank it
like you want to rotate down how does it
it continues to spin you just have no
power so you're just trying to find a
place kind of like and then in the end
you pull up pull everything up and it
just kind of
flops down
okay because i was wondering what if
it's it never just stops it flares no
who developed that leonardo da vinci i
think he came up with did he come up
with that oh like the helicopter he had
the first sort of idea for that with the
aerial screw i was just in rome actually
italy those romans man they knew they
were way ahead of time who's who's
better that the other italians yeah i
was gonna say the intelligence of the
romans yeah
they do um
yeah all that stuff that's that they've
done [ __ ] crazy man italians are the
romans
mexicans
but you know all that stuff weeks yeah
the colosseum and all that have you been
yeah yeah that's fascinating pretty
amazing the vatican vatican oh man i was
right now
when you were there was it like shoulder
to shoulder i went a long time ago okay
i went there uh
about five couples went my wife really
wanted to go i didn't want to go
uh
i said
you know everything i read up on it you
know
they organize religion a lot of pocket
you know a lot of pickpocketing over
there and
certain people is there anybody that has
more money than the catholic church
besides the pga tour yeah the
uh give me give me a pocket full of
money let me walk in compton you know
why do i have to travel all over there
and get robbed
and so
i went
and
the the best thing about the whole trip
was after we went to the vatican
my wife got back in our tour car that we
had in two vehicles
and she just cried her heart out and all
she said was thank you thank you so much
it was such an impact so that made the
whole trip oh yeah
it's uh
you know i didn't really travel as a kid
but i think you want to you want to go
and see some of those things that
you know you end up seeing in a book the
all the time
oh look at the travel channel my
grandmother used to watch midnight mass
from the vatican and you know who
wouldn't what kids wouldn't want to well
i don't want to go to church but i would
like to see it i'm not even an art like
i don't really have a deep appreciation
for art but when i went into that my i
was blown away was just completely blown
you go to the louvre
my wife wanted to go to the louvre she
said well you want to go to the louvre
as there was something david some of the
couples were going that's in florence
right yeah yeah you said that beautiful
beautiful and i just told my wife i said
detail all of a sudden we lived all our
lives here and we got a museum right
here in downtown l.a
i said
and you've never want to go to the
museum all of a sudden now it's over
there you want to go to the museum if
you want to go
i said no but i don't have you know you
can
or do you want to go see that
so
uh
her and i and another guy we stood back
the other couples went and they said
that that was the worst thing they had
ever done it was just like this you know
it was it was
yeah if it's going to be like that
forget it so i went it was not like go
ahead you went like that bumper like
it was just like a cup i was there a
couple weeks ago oh really it was like
nobody was there oh that's because of
the painting yeah because the pandemic
they're still open uh yeah it's open
it's crazy because people the tour guide
was like hey let me take a picture of
you in front of the statue never have
has this been uh you've been able to do
this because so out of the group of
about eight people that went
only one lady one lady got to get close
enough
to see the mona lisa
and they they all said so the mona lisa
is just like that just a little bit
it's in france
you know like i guess air conditioning
all this stuff so when you look at it's
not very big but when you look at it up
close you can see all the the other
beautiful little cracks in the paint
yeah you know right now i i didn't go
but at all see why i don't want to see a
piece of [ __ ] like that
when they got the bucket yeah these
girls are the doctors
it's got cracks in it
but uh that that stuff is uh like you
like that stuff right you like traveling
i love traveling i love going to europe
i go once i try to go once or twice a
year you know what i like to do is i
like i like to fly part of the journey
for me is the experience when you go fly
you know like the beds oh yeah yeah oh
yeah i love that that's my that's part
of the trip you know so i love to do
that who has the best uh the best i mean
i haven't flown on the best but what is
it like qantas or or like uh the the the
middle eastern airlines the the asian
airlines i went to i went to israel
foreign israel and the plane was so old
that they said hey who who who won the
world series in 1954. they didn't have
any wi-fi so they would go ask the
passengers if somebody had a question
oh yeah they got wi-fi if you're going
[ __ ] 18 hours with no wi-fi
you might as well get yourself in a
[ __ ] brown bag it takes to like to
lunch just a [ __ ] hamburger by itself
i flew american airlines and i i i the
flight attendant is walking by and say
hey what's the wi-fi what's the you know
password whatever she's like and she
just laughed at me
she's like you see the cigarette trace
there's no wi-fi in here we're not
trying to fly in a plane that still has
ashtrays yeah [ __ ] seal shut i
learned something america coming back
when i came back to the airport
uh that's first time i i started with
this bleeding ulcer stuff so i'm passing
blood like a good thing and i'm sitting
on first class
and my wife was getting scared she
didn't know what was going on she just
knew that i wasn't feeling good i told
her i had diarrhea
so she's beautiful she was up there i i
told her if you're gonna lie if that's
your comfort story
so so i told her
i said don't worry she knows i don't go
to the doctor much i don't get sick i
said when i get home i said first thing
i'm gonna do i'll take a shower and i'll
go straight to the doctor well the first
thing you do is gonna hide those cases
drop about a seven eleven on the way
home so
as we got a little
into this flight i told the flight
attendant
you better have a wheelchair for me when
i get home like when we land
so i feel that painful it went painful
just so weak i'd lost my blood yeah so
i'm pale oh uh one of the one of the
people that went with us she was a uh
she used to be a cop she was teaching
ucla she's a paramedic certified
paramedic she still rides an ambulance
today
and
[Laughter]
no matter what
okay go ahead sorry
it's gonna start now i've done the first
one i told her i was diaphoretic she
says how do you know that word i said i
used to watch emergency all the time
they use that word diet for reading
that's what it is so shouldn't put you
on ringers like tate no they had that on
emergency too so which is just salt
water when you get back and you're in a
wheelchair
you go in front of everybody they put
it's like the airline the airport
died on the street not with us or in the
airport
and i told the wife just get me straight
straight to the hospital you went from
there did they pull an ambulance up air
side to like no no my daughter was there
they pulled it up they learned it wheel
chaired me i got in the car let's go
straight to
straight to the uh you ever flown with
somebody with handcuffs on no
have you done
uh
with a couple dudes they're probably
pretty big dudes lean they got the badge
they got the guy in the middle like that
they said
they sent you to go get somebody from
another state yeah or another country
brought them back no not another country
i've seen that in some do they fly
usually at night or they fly just
whenever no just whatever what do people
have to wear they they put on a leg
brace so they can't run they can't
can't do much
have they ever been unruly on the plane
no usually pretty good yeah i've only
flown one but
nobody's ever unruly with me anyway
do everybody get arrested do you want to
go with the truth where marshall's still
flying
oh yeah i'm sure they do that's i hear i
hear about that they do i've never seen
them i guess it's a great how you know
you don't want to see get it there
check this out which will be a good
segue
i tell her take me straight to the
hospital
so we're driving i said but before we
get to the hospital i want you to stop
at this place i want a burrito
she says gill you're sick you can't beat
i said hey it'll be paid for she says
you'll throw it i said who cares it's
already paid for
just stop and give me burrito so we
stopped by this place the local place
where i grew up
my soul mate
mario's
uh tacos when how long has it been there
mario stockholm mario taco's had one
little tiny corner he's been there since
the
uh
jet since the late 60s
just a little place it used to belong to
his aunt he ended up taking it over now
he's got a big place a bigger right on
the corner of whittier and durfee marios
tacos
so
i went to the hospital she i said you
just go home
get this stuff off clean up do whatever
you got to do
i'm going to stay here she says you
don't know what you're going to i said
trust me
i went inside
they looked at me and they said whoa so
the bottom line they kept me mario's
tacos
which was the place that i grew up with
very dear friends
i went to uh the doctor this morning as
i said before coming down here just for
a quick checkup
i
hadn't had anything to eat so i stopped
at mario's tacos and when i told them i
was coming down to do a podcast with a
george lopez show
they sent food
right there all right right here
yeah just just you can one of us just so
you can
there's two bean and cheese and i think
there's two
green chilies oh yeah so we're going to
sample them right now yeah oh yeah goat
go for it not me i'm full we can that's
green i need a green chili one man is
this is this the one i should eat yeah
no i don't care which one do you eat
meat oh green chili yeah that one's good
oh yeah i don't mess with that it's not
hot there there's no there's a stomach i
take your previous it today
i actually did you did i've been dealing
with some heartburn i'm 27. what the
[ __ ] going on what is that heart i had
some last night man that was awful i
don't know what the hell is going on i'm
like 27 i'm getting where are you going
to stress yeah maybe i eat like remember
how come you don't look like you eat
like [ __ ] well because good metabolism
you know can i go to the bathroom real
quick yeah i didn't have a metabolism
the doctor told me a man you're the only
person in the world that doesn't have a
metabolism
and cheese and another green one left
me the green one hey uh did we take care
of him we didn't even hardly talk
about him like what do we do like [ __ ]
that one up man oh no no no that was our
dude right there yeah he was good i mean
we're still taping as far as i mean i
know but i mean i didn't have a good
time i had a good time well yeah i had a
good time and he got me on
twitch he got you on he's gonna do it i
like him it's exciting yeah no he's a
cool guy it's a great show and i don't
think we got any numbers at all but like
i mean followed by like millions of
people like he's he's a very big we're
doing the talent showing twitch all
right i love it do you think he wants to
do it you know i i i do i i like him
uh
i was watching last week's show this
morning it dropped
and who was that it was just me and you
yeah
and i talked to you about uh
i had received a message from angelo
and told him that uh
he invited me down come down to what i
call my mama and no no you didn't call
him a name
and he said come on down and i said i'll
get jordan you see bring george down
away i said yeah i'll see if george will
go i'm going over there and
i told you that last week
and then i would talk to myself third
person
on the air you said
okay let's go
and i i didn't realize it till today
that we didn't go
and i was just looking at hey i said
that i i thought you were great man your
dude was still there i didn't know but i
said we were taking care of the man that
we served that we service them yeah oh
yeah that's [ __ ] great man yeah thank
you twitch it's about i've enjoyed the
hell out of this listen you know as i've
gotten older i've met pretty much
everybody like around people that want
to meet but when you meet some like
doing this is a little bit different i
wasn't as excited in the beginning but
you realize that it's something that you
can do first of all you don't know but
like when people come on like you can
tell i don't think we've ever had
somebody that wasn't wasn't cool i don't
know no i i'd agree no it's just it's
been great it's fun everything's a good
time
to do this oh dude man thank you man i
mean
that's some good [ __ ]
i watched your comedy for
many years i watched your specials and
i wake up in the middle i used to you
know go to you know nick at night yep oh
yeah
all those kids that are you jumping on
the terrorists
all those kids that are terrorized by
that [ __ ] song he's one of those
generations oh no absolutely because if
you're if you're in your let's say
you're 30. my show would have started if
somebody was 10 years old they were
watching it yeah no like my demographic
i tell people about the show they're
like oh dude i grew up naked yeah i used
you know i get scared i'd sleep with my
yeah my mom my dad's out of town but i
wake up on the tv oh man that was me
yeah this is i was damn good that's good
you like it yeah there you go i'm not
officially officially approved mario
mario's
but did he make these before he left her
yeah yeah yeah everything was his i'm
not i'm not just i'm not just
smoke blowing do you eat a lot of
mexican food
i you won't find any good ones for
mexican food but you can't really find
no very good mexican there's some good
street food uh in portland
um
what do people use obviously i started
the podcast talking about chipotle
what did you grow up eating like
what's it is there a cuisine up there in
portland that like moose
eat inside the hotel you've got good
food though like portland's like stew or
pacific rim fish i mean we got i don't
know if portland's like really known for
anything that's a nice way to insult you
need those pacific rim
i think i don't know if portland's known
for any like
i think so right i think that's what
a real pacific
a lot of people you know
what do you think is that an insult
switzerland but but uh yeah
like that what's the chain over but it's
more like
they got this steakhouse called the
ringside steakhouse
it's been there for years that's like
experience top ten steakhouse in the
country okay hey
challenge
ringside steakhouse against
stephen's steakhouse where's steven
steakhouse local local not my private
right where the uh can you guys come up
to portland i'll take you
we'll take you out i'll bring some [ __ ]
over here yeah
huh
is stephen is steven still alive yeah
steakhouse showdown jimmy the son runs
it now hey steakhouse royale yeah there
you go
what do people eat over what do they do
we don't there i mean we just eat
but they stuff it or anything like oh
the steak yeah i don't know what they do
it's just it's good though this is good
yeah like manny's in
minneapolis
or del frisco's
you've obviously traveled a lot more
than you think i have i i have you know
i and when i travel did you go did you
ever go to costa mesa or you just kind
of keep it right there yeah
i travel but i don't normally go that
far away from the hotel with cops and we
go someplace especially uh
you've been to commander's palace yes
you've been in new orleans no oh man
dude
commander's palace
sounds badass
everything right with your name they you
know they're all lined up oh yeah right
so it's uh
how long has it been there been a long
time but cuisine incredible whatever
whatever you get
they play jazz they come around
i also ate at a breakfast place there
what's the it's really known for the
yeah that was the bananas
yeah that place was green and white yes
it's like old well it's like there's
cafe dumont which is
but there's like a breakfast you ever
had a beignet yeah
that's good like a like a sopapilla with
a lot of powdered sugar
commander's palace uh founded 1893.
wow
they didn't have chorizo back then
either they did no they were still
trying to figure out how to make it yeah
but i grew up eating just everything but
mexican food's always been my favorite
yeah this tabernacle has tackled a few
of everything yeah
what is like japanese yeah what what is
the
do you can people still eat like that i
guess if you eat a lot of meat man like
your body can't
so at some point that gives you a
younger guy
acid reflux you don't want that for the
rest of your life but i think what they
say nobody we didn't ever eat in
portions like you go to a place
like in where they go to um in in
memphis with the ribs
and
they're they're hanging over the plate
and everybody's like all right and then
later on at night you know for the next
[ __ ] two years
but
the larger portions doesn't necessarily
mean even if it's great i forget uh uh
corki's or wherever we went to get got
ribs that they would fly him out you
know like when i was in hawaii we would
take care of san fernando where i grew
up and we would have them flight
come on let's do haunted hills yeah
that's good the local local
local market in and out doesn't travel
tamales travel well in and out when
somebody goes hey i bring my friend some
somebody out from portland but then
because they're like
we haven't in and out in oregon now oh
you do about an hour from portland yeah
no nice south they finally pulled
there's not a lot of those we didn't
have chick-fil-a for we have chick-fil-a
now
that's one of my favorite facts
but there was a barbecue place that i
went to in saint louis it was really
good and all the cops went there there
was a line on the outside he loves
knocking no actually you know it's
really good loves the line
the uh no no but that there's still some
of those places that you know
commander's palace what's out here
that's uh that's been around forever not
a lot no
i'm trying to i what okay so would you
go to harborough street like old-timey
civic dining car how long have they been
around then they closed man the pacific
dining car
i think was in uh training day
is there okay so this is where i go for
mexican food clothes yeah but
temporarily no that's too far man that's
too far okay where do i go
where do you live where are you staying
well
uh beverly or um west hollywood
i don't know that's out of my rd i don't
know
sunset um
this is all right el compadre is evident
all right i'm just saying
[Music]
on sunset right not too far away from
dodger stadium that's a different one oh
okay
that one i went to after the game and
there was some cholo out there he had a
big ep
right i go what are the elvis presley
they didn't think that was funny
you know when you heard you know when
you heard of solo when they say hey [ __ ]
you that means they hurt me
they do that if they say like if they
laugh then they're laughing but what i
love is that big ass ep
i said our love is presley he [ __ ] you
and then he saw it was me and then
he still didn't laugh but he said he was
gonna keep an eye on my car
they said echo park yeah that's what i
get for trying like the dude was you
know those dudes don't
you know what they don't yeah they're
not really uh the best people that joke
no they're not friendly
yeah i was born
go [ __ ] myself and then he said he would
watch my car so that's oh that's nice
and fences in the community also the boa
steakhouse that's probably right near
where you are yes in uh
that's near uh
this new world
uh no i i've been there though i've been
there i was there a couple of times nice
man you get up there don't remember
we're gonna have to take a field trip
over there oh yeah
nice man it's on sunset up at the top
top yep it's really nice they'll
validate your car
you go up to the top there there's about
the closest in there sometimes
all right let's wrap it up grab yeah
this was great uh austin show thank you
for coming thank you for having me
that's been awesome
yeah
this is damn good i'm not just blowing
smoke this is awesome but don't have
heart what do you don't ask the reflex
don't worry i took my private sect yeah
i got some stuff in mexico that the the
anthony keatis well they got it
stuff
and uh it works you popped your shirt
right huh yeah thanks guys
with cocaine at walmart in mexico yeah i
think mario and his sister norma for the
food for mike mario and norman thank you
very much
i can't thank you enough everybody loved
it the guy from portland oregon wanted
to take a trip all the way down there
and it's just to have something
to fly
anyways all right let's go awesome all
right thank you guys thank you so much
thank you so much for coming
tell the people where to find you
twist.tv austin show hey literally there
we go
hey
boy i'm doing my podcast you're on the
phone hello hey did you see the
nightstalker thing on netflix
what's that do you see the nightstalker
documentary on netflix
no i haven't seen netflix go uh the guy
one of the detectives latino guys in
here gills say what's up gil what's up
what's up
what's up what's happening my man
yeah
i'll say it
how about me
is he on it no no
hey i'll send uh i'll send you guys some
uh links you could look at
okay you guys know literally i'm good
man
yeah i'll call you back from there i'll
call you in the car you all right
all right bye all right
all right
so tv slash
yeah when i was growing up interesting
that was my idol he tripped into the
golfer now he's calling you that's
amazing damn beautiful
you got my inspiring notes
how about
that pretty good impressive that's
important good dude too yeah that's
awesome he's like me loners like us like
you spent a lot of time alone yeah not
like you got a girlfriend a healthy
relationship oh no not you you live
alone by yourself oh yeah with you so
you live alone by yourself so that's
good yeah getting it alone and then
living alone by yourself is different
yeah you're right right yes if i said if
you would say i live alone but you have
two rumors so now okay i created a new
phrase i live alone by myself that's
great that's a good point because now
you know that it's different than living
in a couple dudes and i hate i can't do
roommates
if it doesn't fit the mexican will make
it fit that's true what would you
suggest for him a
condo or
in l.a
an l.a condo or house condo condo okay i
think
i think one of those one of those
buildings that they that they are redo
i think that's better i like new i like
new it's safer
up higher apart almost like the rich
carlton up there yep yep downtown l.a
just take over the penthouse
there's some places over there you know
i had a building had a place in uh
figaro and seventh and the guy had this
big building and he was letting a couple
lakers stay in there
people they were involved with didn't
know but then
so then he gave us stuff man
yeah it was it was a well said i've
already said too much but it was
supposed to be a two-year lease free and
he was using the guys to give him you
know leases then he would say guess who
you know who's in here it was a great
place that made me think like i was in
new york because corner of 7th and
figueroa right there everything's all
built up now yeah but that guy in a year
that guy came and said hey man uh
you know
gotta let you guys move out that two
years [ __ ] said that one year
yeah they sold it all out and now
downtown you can't get you can't get a
place down yeah no that was it was fun
it's nice yeah i'll i'll be looking i'll
be looking west hollywood downtown don't
tell me i'm what we'll see
well they're doing all that stuff like
down in west hollywood like all that
stuff is changing they're like
destroying my blocks they're just
creating entirely new it's like shops
and then residential on top of it look
right there on uh like um
fairfax and santa monica where the
that they have now they have like like
right across
i'm right now i'm staying right next to
the beverly center right now so i'm on
la cienega oh cool you just drive real
close you just that's really close to
west oh yeah i think technically it's
yeah that's right there next to uh
cedar city basins yeah it's right
exactly
tomorrow yeah there you go
11 o'clock my no my appointment's at 12.
you're going to the hospital you're
going to that little clinic no i'm going
to the doctor's office
he works out of cedars but he's got his
own
place in beverly hills
we started with the animals we end with
the enemas that's right
so you have millions of uh millions of
followers right how does that happen
like how did how does it happen how does
it build like for somebody like uh it it
goes not up it goes in waves right yeah
so like you know it's hard to really
describe how it happens but a lot of
times you have a big moment right like
you have a big show and then usually a
lot of followers come from that and then
what was the big show that you had that
uh i mean i've had i've had uh you know
my biggest show had like 187 000 live
concurrent viewers which is you know
like it's like a stadium 187 000 people
um that was one of the bigger ones that
i've had i've had several over a hundred
thousand
um and you know they built so like you
know those big shows happen then another
guest is like hey i want to be on that
show and then it kind of you know builds
and you just kind of uh it just kind of
goes organically i don't know how to
really describe it you're producing your
stuff and you're yeah i've got i've got
a team of course i'm not you know i'm
not doing it completely but this is what
like all those guys were doing that were
creating games mark toddson and goodman
and those guys like but now through this
it's that that's what my dad says my
dad's like hey you're just you know
totally let's make a deal and it's all
all that stuff he's like go look at all
the people that were doing it back then
you know pioneering and mark goodson
good todman and goodson or something
like that and then it was merv griffin
and who else
right
wow uh card sharks
what's my lion big big money no whammies
what's that um
but all those uh
the price is right okay i got one
question for you this is off topic yup
who's your favorite comedian of all time
ultimate richard pryor living living
love it
powerful answer
any and then any and you may not have it
send all the complaints to uh
george loves louie.com
[Laughter]
no it's brilliant dude man like you know
for whatever hey listen everybody's for
whatever whatever is whatever nobody's
uh solvent everybody's a little bit
twisted and that makes it that's what
makes humor yeah well i wouldn't let him
jack up in the back of my range rover
but
any are there any sort of like younger
comics you've seen he's been like oh
that's that's really cool like sort of
next generation of people i don't know
man like those dudes like i don't know i
don't really kind of pay attention but i
wish i did because there's some really
funny ones but there's some a lot of
them are are
you know
just doing their own thing like that
they don't really need an audience
you know yeah
yeah so so clubhouse is more of an audio
do you think they'll go video no i don't
know because that's what twitch is i
don't think that's all i've heard about
clubbing this is one thing that i'm not
really super familiar with it's like
sort of like i've heard about it a lot
of businesses and like professionals use
it you think so yeah yeah yeah a lot of
people that's what i've seen well you
can start a limited
uh
dealing with clubhouse but
the people the times that i have the
people that i'm listening are business
people yeah it's like it's like you know
people that are really interested in
like sophisticated like software and
like and you know a lot of stuff and you
know yeah but here it's like
boom it's fast yeah it moves fast oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah there's no there's
no preamble spit on your hand and let's
go
it's true
that's my new show that's come out twist
spit on your head
george look at that how do i start that
one that's a good one i got a bunch of
pesto
secure that secure the trademark before
this
all right they're not going to let me in
the whole recovery anymore all right no
no no they're awesome they look pretty
good
all right graham great stuff what
else for coming out thank you leave us
voicemails eight one eight five three
three eighteen forty three is there
anyone from any good ones from uh no we
have one guy who keeps calling from an
unknown number who literally left thirty
voicemails
and uh i don't know uh
he's taking up a lot of the inbox right
now so ask us real questions ask george
real questions
i have no idea it's just rambling
stories it's uh i'll stop calling
[Laughter]
awesome but good stuff it's a great show
thank you it's a very old school to have
to leave a message on there
when you call people do you leave
messages they say nothing sometimes i
don't [ __ ] say they say most of the
time i hang up and then i text and be
like that's that's what i'm doing now
most of the time
because i don't like to leave messages
there's no voicemail there's no call
that's kind of my most of the time
nobody listens to your message anyway
because a lot of times i'm just calling
to say hey what's up you know i don't
have anything in particular are you
familiar with what that dodger picture
is going through
can we talk about that
i don't care so what's his name trevor
bauer trevor bauer so trevor bauer
is involved in a
dispute with a woman
because of rough sex and text messages
oh [ __ ] um and he's a uh baseball player
and
it's like one of those things of consent
you know yeah and
non-consent but she has text messages
she has she he has
text messages that he's received from
her where she's consenting to all this
stuff oh interesting the complaint is
that he went too far oh and she's got
she went to the hospital she was bruised
up
alleged that he beat her up and so
that's a tough one came under
investigation now he hasn't been
pitching
and they've just given him more time but
it seems like it's um
i mean you don't want to try anything in
the in the news because it's you know
i've heard about people that like to be
hit though
oh there there's oh yeah there is no
doubt
there's like some people that really
enjoy that kind of thing and that's why
i even if somebody were like hey hit me
i'd be like
i don't know i know that's what makes it
so tricky too is i don't know too much
about it but i know these text messages
exist which sort of okay they're into
this space to some degree but still did
he go too far it's just yeah
because you can technically you can
whatever all consent at any moment you
know it means like at certain points
like but it's all taking place
you know in kind of like real time yeah
yeah but if you knock her out she can't
comp she can't stop don't yeah uh-huh
everybody knows ever since they left
bill cosby you're not the savior
no it's it's tragic because
although you can't
try him in the public eye
that's what people are doing you know
because
he's staying now whether he's found
innocent or not
he is stained because he's known as
a deviant yeah and what point at what
point did the dodgers like terminate
that because there's a there's a
commitment yeah for really what you do
on the field i'm sure there's probably
like a
a clause in their
class that's behavior
you didn't do it's not
it's not
it's not against the law we're concerned
yeah it's a weird sound so it's a tough
really way that's why i just let girls
whip me with the holes
if i were a betty bit on your hand
if i were betting man i'd say he'd never
be on the ball field again with the
dodgers
you know because the public image you
know and what they've got to lose
they'll pay him they'll give him
whatever he wants
uh but i did
you know the dodgers are
they're very family oriented public
oriented
and that's a big
uh
big hill businesses yeah they'll pay a
big game out of there especially in l.a
i mean you know we're they're so kind of
you know yeah
out here where
most of the people are like
yeah they'll be staying away for a while
because he's i mean he's for what he
does he's amazing yeah and he's a great
pitcher
yeah but what if he hit you with the
ball and you came is that against
that's it
all right thanks everyone this is great
thank you
you